[Applause]
do you remember
um that is not only the 90210 theme song
also the song i lost my hand virginity
to
in case you haven't guessed
in case you haven't guessed tori
spelling is our guest today this is a
dream of course you know her uh she's
famous and iconic for playing donna
martin on the original 90210 probably my
favorite character of any show of all
time she's written six books she's
created television show she's now
starring in a show called messiness on
mtv it's kind of like america's funniest
home videos but like the adult version
that people actually want to watch
and it's where like tori spelling and
snooki from the jersey shore they sort
of
poke fun at themselves and people they
show videos of people doing dumb things
so yeah if you enjoy watching drunk
people humiliate themselves watch the
show messiness or my ig stories
tori spelling um
she was a hero of mine growing up and
after sitting with her for a couple
hours she's even more of a hero
not only is she hilarious in this
interview she's smart she's self-aware
she also drinks cheap rose which is
basically the only thing i look for in a
friend i know i love that i emily did
edit this episode we had to cut a couple
things out because we got
messy comically drunk
loose
so
i did blab most of the time but to be
fair i feel like
i feel like we just got very casual and
it was more of a hang
mm-hmm you know
emily what's your diagnosis of i had a
great time the parts i remember yeah
that's the thing that's right we got a
little too wasted why were we so drunk
this is a really fun one to edit because
i was there but when i watched it it was
like i wasn't cause i didn't remember it
i know because you spent most of the
time trying to breastfeed hedgehogs
she brought little mini albino hedgehogs
so that does happen on the show uh and i
just want to be very clear in this
episode i say like a lot it was it's
really grating but i was
very drunk so i just want to be very
clear i stand by everything i said i
just don't remember saying
any of it yeah but it's good to stand by
it and then i want to let you guys know
that we are on the road you guys know
where to find tickets whitneycomings.com
i don't want to bore you with all the
shows but we should be very clear that
we are selling exclusive merch at the
live shows of the touch me tour you
cannot buy it online i am wearing it now
as you can see so the airbrushed
sexually um charged
perfectly trashy tour shirts we have it
in a blush and a black that's right
summer was a bummer but not name not now
and then we've got pin packs that i'm
obsessed with i put them on my
sorry that noise this one is only
available at tour this pin pack is the
tour pin pack the one with the horseshoe
there's a little bikini tour if you look
at my denim jackets i've been putting
them on they look really good and then
online we have a different pin pack we
got this pin pack that has whitney's
horse whitney and her dog so he has a
little demon cherub and then a good for
you pin which we i put on my backpack
i've been putting it on my purse
my nipples
emily plot twist wearing them like
earrings
also just really quick iowa we are
coming to the riverside casino on
october 14th and then we're going to des
moines and
on october 15th the name of the venue is
what i blame for all my problems in life
it's called the hoyt sherman place
i do comedy just in places i think it's
just a place iowa look i know a lot
about iowa and i want you guys to know a
lot about me
so come see the shows i know that iowa's
called the hawkeye state
i know that you guys made the first
electronic computer it was built by iowa
state researchers in the 1930s
and i know that io has more golf courses
per capita than any other state which
means you guys have cash to burn
okay you like frustrating experiences
so kind of the merch booth
we even moved one of the shows so it
didn't fall on the same day as the
university of high iowa homecoming games
because we want to go to the game
i want to go to homecoming with a senior
because we come dressed up in gowns and
crowds like this wrong coming
enjoy toy spelling everyone this one is
a wild journey doozy doozy it is a doozy
it is it is chock full of hilarious
moments insightful really poignant
moments
she's vulnerable she's honest she's
saying things i've not i saw a side of
her i've not seen before and i'm a big
fan yeah and also she's sort of the way
that she fearlessly is so vulnerable and
talking about public feedback and stuff
you know it's so specific to her but
also so relatable to everybody because
whether you have 10 million followers or
10 followers any kind of negativity you
get online it's still really hard to
navigate you know it's still the same
ratio so she had some like really
amazing you know thoughts on that um i
feel like i grew a lot it made me kind
of um
she had 90 210 insightful things to say
and i threw up
you did throw up so did she i think
and i got hives messiness enjoy torrey
smelling yay
well first of all for those of you
watching the show you will notice that
i've been dethroned
by a legend
an icon a star
the only bitch in the game that i would
allow to sit in my seat
tori spelling is here
and may i say how we got around to doing
this
yeah of course so you're sitting in my
seat because there's something very
surreal going on here because
i it's my nightmare to meet you
uh nightmare i'm obsessed with you i
okay yeah okay i am do you agree what
i'm i may i'm obsessed with you for many
many reasons we can get into it later i
bring you up like you know when i talk
about like characters and tv shows like
like how does where is the donna martin
at all where is the like what tori like
what she did with that character you
know it's like i bring up your
performance a lot in that and i bring up
you a lot in your real life the way
you've been so relentlessly authentic
and fucking fear like you're one of the
few people that i'm like
that bitch has balls really it's it's
rare that i'm like in awe of someone's
um
i don't want to say courage or bravery
because i feel like when people call
women brave it means like we go on
camera without makeup but she's so brave
like that's not right i would never i
didn't have to
that's right that's never happening
but like talk about my debt all day long
because i'm never not working
on campus
because i cannot stop behind this
fucking armani foundation um but uh
i i just
to meet you is is i i always thought it
would be like awkward and uncomfortable
and now all of a sudden we've been
texting and i feel like we're friends
and it's not appropriate
not appropriate i feel like we're close
to friends that i should sing um no
because i feel the same way
why do you get so comfortable with you
it's weird i don't know but i've always
like i follow you okay so we kind of met
through clubhouse that's right
and i remember it was like my first
night on clubhouse and all of a sudden i
saw you pop in and i was like oh whitney
cummings is on clubhouse and i was like
spelling sunglasses and i was like got
really nervous and i was like play cool
play cool and i can still remember which
shows how obsessed i am with you that
you're like oh sorry i'm on nyquil or
something and i'm
yeah
can i tell you i was okay i was i think
i'm going to be on next season of
messiness with some of the things i did
on michael over the the pandemic we're
going to talk about yeah because to me
like you have just been consistently
someone that
has like handled so many just ridiculous
situations with so much grace and humor
thank you and that to me is the key to
success alternative like the alternative
wasn't pretty it was just going down the
spiral of everyone saying things and i
was like well screw it beat him to the
punch no punch what no what yeah beat
him to the pond sure yeah
and so now i guess the only way that i
will sum you up just in terms of who you
are
is that we've been texting back and
forth
uh it took me when i say months to ask
you to be on the podcast i was like
i can't like i can't know like what she
said like i just i like finally asked
like yeah when like it was like
no big d it made me feel so comfortable
right away because it's my nightmare
to want to be friends with somebody and
then you're like so can you give me a
couple hours of your time and now we
have to get into logistics and like work
stuff
yeah but i mean
i watch your stuff like i know it's a
good time and everyone drinks and
i don't know is that you just spit all
over me i just spit oh my god
[Laughter]
when i say in a pandemic
i just spewed every droplet in my person
on torres valley on on it was like a
pretty it was almost a gleek
it was
yeah like it was like borderline spits
flash
i mean that was um
and i love you even more now because you
said something
most people would just pretend it didn't
happen and the whole interview would
have one of you sorry
you're just like you just spit all over
mute
you're like that you're just like like
the realist
you're the realist some people don't
like it they're like too much a lot of
people can't handle it a lot of people
conflate like realness and honesty with
like personal attacks criticisms or
being ostentatious or something okay
because they get jealous because they
don't have the same kind of freedom you
have
i guess so
it's so it's it's a lot of people don't
understand how um
uh liberated i was just about to say
that word that's what it was for me it
was cathartic it was just like ugh
and now i mean i have really thick skin
yeah
but it was just like to put it all out
there i don't know and some people are
like oh she's gone too far now it's just
all out there she's a mess like it's
just like uh usually when someone calls
me a bitch it just means i i've started
to uh redefine these words that i always
thought were insults so if someone calls
you a bitch it probably just means you
have self-respect so when someone's like
she's a bitch i'm like i must be doing
something right i must have like claimed
my space i must have stood up for myself
i must have had good boundaries and when
someone uh calls you a mess i'm learning
it either means you're having more fun
than them
yeah or you're authentic and don't take
yourself as seriously and they need to
reduce you to like oh that person's just
like a hot mess yeah it's like no i'm
just having the best time and you're not
yeah i don't know what best time but
yeah
so last night um
you we were texting and you sent me a
text like 11 30 and you were like just
took an ambien on the way to the fridge
yeah and i was like this is just like me
what's up
okay so i'm obsessed so here's wild so
i'm just like totally gonna put out
there and someone will do it but
whatever uh i want to do an ambient
cookbook
with celebrities it's a gym if anyone
would be
it by the way you put it out there all
the money i mean it's it's just throw i
mean that is the things created
i mean they're genius
i used to take ambien i do lunesta now
because the am i even tried that the
ambien i almost poked my eye out on
chicken carcass
so
i was choked on a chicken bone
like falling asleep the one time it
wasn't intentional and i i would wake up
and i will have just like i sleep eat
when i take auntie
and especially a time when i was like
depriving myself of food so much i was
like anorexic at the time so i would
wake up and i would wake up the next day
i mean i used to there would be like
bloody footprints everywhere that i
realized later was like barbecue sauce
and like ketchup and stuff but i would
wake up and just like what did i do like
what have i done and then it would like
i'd follow these little barbecue sauce
um uh footsteps to like just like a
chicken carcass that i had like not
eaten like an apple
like an animal this is before ring
cameras i wish i had footage of that i
could make so much money on only fans
what happens to you on ambien cause
you're not supposed to get on ambien and
start walking you're supposed to get in
bed and then take it
okay i do that but then i get out of bed
and
but here we go that's the plan like back
me up here
you know what you're doing but for some
reason you don't give a fuck and you're
like
i'm on am and you're like i'm gonna eat
and i know i shouldn't have because i
spent all day like dieting and like not
eating a thing and i'm gonna eat right
now i'm gonna eat something bad and bad
i might devour this entire bag of
ruffles yeah and and then you're like
you think about it for a second you're
like and i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
yeah i eat crazy shit though yeah i
crazy shit i love piecing sorry i'm
interrupting oh my god i love it so much
where's the gun so i am
so bad with interrupting because i just
get so excited but i started taking
prozac and i have so much respect for
you and love you that i'm not
interrupting you but i'm normally really
bad about it me too but i feel like
that's a conversation women do that like
men like
i was like if you wait too long then
it's over yeah i forgot i thought it was
yes like it's a but it's an
experience yeah you're not interrupting
me you're i'm bombing and you're
thinking of something better and i'm
like and i'm like please take the ball
like there's no i'm like psyched that
you're saving me from a story that's
going nowhere oh my gosh because there
was some no peace oh i was gonna say
piecing together is really fun though
the next morning of what you've eaten
and retracing it is it is csi it really
is totally you're like what is this this
clothes like where yeah you're putting
together the pieces of like okay orange
rinds clothes why is there one size 12
basketball shoe
whose is this
it is like a fuck goes a whole different
direction but
i
and then i like to go to my email and go
all right let's go to my set folder and
see who i fired last night on ambien who
by the way doesn't even work for me
i once fired oh fired a lawyer at a
company called logan loeb didn't work
for me
shut up on ambien oh yeah i broke up
with people i wasn't dating i was like
look i just don't think it's working out
they're like what
and they're like you have to explain to
my wife that you just broke up with me
and we weren't together like the things
i did on ambien were i don't want
ambient text how many milligrams you
want
12.5 well we need up your dosage there's
more it's a better color there's more
you only take one at a time
that's the highest
i took traffic have you ever taken
trazadone yeah it gave me nightmares and
like totally i had wild dreams on that
hated it
but with my ambien so here's how my
morning starts okay i wake up and i look
down and i find the crumbs on my shirt
because it starts with that
and you pick it up and you're like what
is this
and you smell it and then you go from
there and then it's on the bed and then
i look at my nightstand and then i
retrace the steps into the kitchen
i find crazy things yeah that and then
you and then you go back and then you
but where what is the value in not
having it in the house see i want to
just go don't have it in the house but
if i don't have the champion no food oh
i was panicking because then i'll get in
the car because i yeah i when i lived um
uh uh it when i was in college there was
a there was like a 7-11 like at the
bottom of my building and i went and i
was like i just need to eat healthy
thing i was on ambien i was ambien
walking i went to the 7-11 and i was
like i'm just getting something healthy
and i ate like five apples you know like
from seven eleven it does like red
apples i'm eating eating them i'm eating
i'm like and i wake up this morning i
kind of feel so bad i ate like five
apples yeah it wasn't something crazy it
wasn't like five cans of soup or like
you know 50 cakes or whatever and then
the next day i went to 7-eleven to get
something else and i saw the apples and
they were covered in saran wrap
why
be like to keep them sandwiched
and then i looked at them i was like oh
no i was like are these always insurance
i was like are they they've always been
in saran wrap or you've is this like a
new thing like since this morning i had
eaten like all of it did it come out
your poop i mean yeah i shit it out
what was that like you know maybe i
didn't maybe it's still in my body oh my
god it's like cherry pits it's just like
that like you know what i did try to do
once to protect myself from my own
ambient binges is have you ever like
sprayed something you don't want to eat
with like windex or like
that's poison yeah okay
i would like if there's like cupcakes or
a cake or something and i'm like eating
it on an ambient like i can't eat any
more of this i'll like spray it with
windex and then put in the trash so that
i won't eat it again and then on ambien
you take it i'll just like get up the
middle oh yeah
so my mother used to um
she's take her ambien because she would
literally she gained so much weight she
i mean she talks about this and because
she would go down and make butter and
mayonnaise sandwiches
you're like
you know what no my dad used to do
peanut butter and mayonnaise there's
something about that generation i'm
gonna try that that they that mayonnaise
was a thing for them so she was doing
this nightly so she told her security
guard
to uh once she'd taken her ambien at a
certain time he had to go lock the
pantry in the refrigerator
i need that guy
right that's the guy i need the person
who will i don't have anyone to do that
i volunteer volunteers tribute okay i
mean because that would help me i also
that makes me think when i first moved
to la i went to the starbucks right next
to saddle ranch on sunset
and i saw um
mike tyson and mike tyson was there with
like five security guards around him you
know i'm like 20 whatever one i'm like
an idiot i think i'm so funny i like go
up to security guards i'm like do you
really think mike tyson needs you to
protect it you know like like 5 000
people make that joke a day like hack
annoying stupid and he just looked at me
and goes oh we're not here to protect
uh him from other people we're here to
protect other people from him
so at any moment they're prepared to
fight him that's what i need between me
and my fridge
someone who's prepared to fight me
every night because i saw what you made
because you sent me pictures last night
on lunesta you had what was it it was a
sausage and cheese it was um you're
giving me too much credit but that could
be in your cook i would probably up
pretend it was that for your cookbook
but we could do better your cookbook
that is such a that is like the first
genuinely good idea i've heard in so
long like i'm jealous
would people yes
yes i mean i think you would do like
well it would be fun to do little videos
like little teasers of it of us on
ambien just doing it uh like we should
do that yeah
do we want money or not how much do we
hate money
i like money i know if we don't do that
we hate money that's such a good idea
right me on lunesta and you on ambien
and we're like yeah maybe no knives or
fire maybe gazpacho something cold
something doesn't involve fire knives or
appliances gazpacho sounds like a bad
idea on ambient lunesta
think of a more boring thing to have so
i'm gonna have gazpacho i know what a
bummer
yeah that would suck what is it no it
was it was gluten-free bread because i'm
trying to not eat gluten because my
doctor said that i'm not absorbing
vitamin b because i eat too much fucking
gluten and so it was gluten free bread i
just put a ton of butter on top of it
and then put it in the toaster and then
there was this like you know this like
cartoon sausages you see and like
you said that but i didn't know what
that meant it was like a
it was like you don't have like a old
sauce in there like and it's got like a
like a little wrapping on the back and
that's
like their shoulders
yeah yeah
totally and it's like got little like
buttholes on the end where they they
yeah and so i i got it like as like
literally as a joke for somebody it was
like a gag gift and i was but on lunesta
everything's on yeah limits
right everything's in play of course and
so i like cut it up i peeled the skin
off because i've evolved and grown and i
don't eat i don't eat coverings anymore
good for you in plastics and um and then
i just cut it and like put it on there
and the fact that i sent it to you means
i really either
want to sabotage this or we're best
friends
i
was so into it actually it made me
hungry and after that like i really went
to town what did you do what happened so
i was jealous because you had a sandwich
i don't usually make sandwiches
that's a very
sorry i don't have gluten free so i just
ate wonder bread and
um
and yeah what's better than one of these
though see it was butter wow that was a
lot of butter i was like that was
i eat but
my here's my my deal with food is like
is
food is like a vehicle for sauces and
dips like i'm a sauce and a dip bitch
like all right yeah so agreed the bread
was the transportation device for the
butter i understand wow
no one's ever put it that way but it's
brilliant or should they ever again and
i'm sorry
yeah and i'm so fascinated by you i've
been thinking about you so much because
i'm like what do you talk to tori
spelling about like there's you've been
asked every question i know so much
about you
i was watching your new show
truly not even like you're on so i need
to talk about your new show um on mtv
now messiness and my brain was like oh
she's just watching it to be nice and
prepared
because i'm just i'm migrating my
reputation i'm known for being so nice
and so prepared on these parts i mean i
was like yeah like you know you know me
but um
i just thought because there's something
god it's so like like watching the show
watching you snooki who i i adore
because to me you would love her i don't
know i know well we did uh i hosted mtv
new year's eve on mtv live like years
ago and it was with the jersey shore oh
okay people um did i miss the countdown
and get it wrong yes i did did i ruin
most young people's new year's eve
absolutely um
because like we were fucking around we
were like drinking and they were like
count down why am i drinking it or not i
am but that's what i'm doing look what
do you want me to do i'll do anything
what do you want me to do i feel like
you're not drinking look what
do you want to drink wine you're double
fisting okay this is let's see well hold
on but this is hard kombucha which is
like this is like a beer and a half this
is six percent alcohol don't just down
this entire thing
no i want you if i puke
i'll hold your hair
no i won't because i yes this is i don't
know what this is
though i'm also holding for those of you
listening uh what looks to me like
robitussin um is this dimetap
uh emily uh
uh drinks something called an apparel
spritz because she is fancy so it's such
a divorced choice
it tastes like salon selectives
but i'm happy for you and i'm trying to
participate what's what's the alcohol in
it is it um
look as someone that just admitted to
eating windex this is gross
it's aperol it's that's not a thing it
is
i don't know what it is that's what it
is like you've never been to capri all
right
it's like you've never had a capri sun
would you have tasted salon selectives
uh of course you've never gotten shampoo
in your mouth
yeah your belair background just came
out i know never ate shampoo as a kid
got it
my nanny was like head back and i was
like okay
is it no tears
oh yeah the no more tears um the
detangler and all remember those shits
can i tell you something like that it
didn't work
but also why did we know that
i was the idiot who was like no more
tears let's see like this doesn't work
like i had
yeah
so you i'm watching messiness and i'm
like this to me is what
all i care about all i care about at
this point people know i'm in 12-step
programs i have codependents i grew up
now call it calm blah boring boring
boring and social trauma we've all been
through it the only
thing i have found
and i've done a lot of things that
anesthetize and i've tried a lot of
things and been to
every whether it's a therapist or i've
been to every
therapists and healer's basement in
venice i've held every stone i've got
every colonic i've had everything up my
butt in me out of me
um
the only times i truly feel like i'm
like lack of better like happy feel
serene is when i have no secrets and
when i'm not trying to be so i'm not
trying you know we stand program you're
only as sick as the secrets you keep and
i don't have any shame and when we
um
show ourselves fully the good the bad
the ugly the shadow self the you know
quote unquote embarrassing things that's
when we get to release shame and have
grace and that's a big part of why
12-step programs when you go in and you
say like yeah i want to cheat i did this
i did heroin and everyone goes me too
and you go
and then that shame engine goes away
and
i'm like in this moment in time where
every everyone that's fucking going down
right people like cancel culture like me
too all stuff these are all people that
were different people
in public than they were in private
right they all had secrets they were all
like fake and to me like the people that
impressed me the most i mean to me like
that is like such a big part of why
you're such a gangster to me because
there's just there's no
i mean maybe they're i don't know i mean
i would if there's secrets i
can't wait for the next book but i just
mean like you are so i hate it when
people say you're unapologetic i hate
that when people say that to me too
they're like you're so unapologetic i'm
like you're implying i should apologize
for something
like you're implying i did something
wrong and i'm not apologizing but you're
just like
it just feels like you're living so hard
and so
real
i try
the amount of damage you do to yourself
by
hiding
your quote-unquote mistakes or
you know moments you're not proud of or
just like human like just
what everybody else does all the time
right
and then we have to be like be the
pariah or like the cathartic like
like when people disapprove of us it's
just like well you've done that too i
know what happens when i judge people
it's like well i've done that of course
they all have like i i mean you watch
movie stars all the time and they're so
like
media trained i mean that's what it was
like my whole life yeah media train like
you know you only say this you like
shorten the story you keep it like that
and like pull it together
and i have a really obviously fun wild
side yeah
and you're too interesting for that
but i do currently like i even have
friends that are like keep it classy
like you know like dumbing it down
almost what does that mean i don't know
because i'm like well this is me what's
what's gonna happen oh because you'll
work with brands that are conservative
and they won't want to work with you i'm
like well then i don't work with them
yeah i'm like kind of at the point where
it's like you either fuck with me or you
don't there is nothing i can do to
change you've made your mind up about me
yeah and any
thing you think about me at this point
is more reflection of you than it is of
me that's exactly it like 100 would be
like i don't know i feel like you
overshot it's like well no some people
are gonna fuck with that and the people
that don't like just like like yeah the
idea that anyone can please everyone all
the time is just like it's magical
thinking and it's a god complex and also
why would you want to
i don't know
like what like
if you pull yourself together you're
going to be doing like activia
commercials
i mean i'm sure they pay well yeah yeah
just fyi we're both available yeah we
will i will literally video myself
shitting i will do whatever you need
um but uh who did those jamie jamie yeah
jamie lee curtis yeah
and everyone's like look how hot she is
i'm still drinking you're not guys are
like looking at her like oh that means
her ass
cheers to like you and me being so
awkward and you being so um patient
and cool about my awkwardness
okay so this started you guys because
i don't know how to work dms and
some how like you damned me and it was
in my
general thing and then i was like found
out how to do because i had like a
gazillion
how to do top ones and they put you in
the top one because if you because
you're verified right right if i'm
verifying if we follow each other you
like see my messages or whatever no but
i didn't see it you blew me off
no i didn't it was in my general and
then when i did top ones i was like i
didn't know i could do that yours came
up and i was like oh my god
immediately it was like i'm so sorry i
never got this
ah sorry
so after watching messiness and just in
general like because i've been like
watching a lot of your interviews and
stuff and we'll get to comedy comedy
haha in one second but uh
saying like that that your experience
like as a one of the most famous people
in the world like as someone that is
someone that
like you know we are
you know similar age-wise but like
that was like you were so much younger
than me i'm 76 i go to dr lancer your
character
for me
was one of the first women on television
that and i know the story of why
obviously because you know your dad
being involved didn't want you to be
sexualized but it was the first time i
saw
a woman be funny and not just be like
like she wants to fuck who's fucking it
wasn't just all about sex even though
you're all in and that's like such a
it's so sad that in this business the
only way that a character on tv at that
time could not be hyper sexualized was
if her family was involved in the
production you know
like but
you know lucille ball i love but you
coming out of that limo and that dress
and like oh my god the playing it real i
remember that red dress and it was and
and and
you weren't like okay that you weren't
laughing like you were trying to get out
of the car
and that is like that is on some leslie
nielsen shit like that's my favorite
that
it's a big deal it's a it's a big deal
and seeing that i remember going like oh
if you're play it straight like you
don't try to make something that's
already funny funny like you play it
real you know and i just remember like
you were really just trying to get out
of the car like that stuck with me
i mean to this day
when something funny's happening i'm
like don't try to be funny just it's
already funny like don't kill the lily
like your instinct
was so incredible ah oh my god those of
you that don't know what i'm talking
about it was when donna went to prom and
her dress couldn't get out of the
thing you probably blacked this all out
and disassociated it no i mean
re-traumatizing dance but yeah oh so
sorry okay got it it's only because
jenny and i do the 90210
omg i i know you just read you just re i
don't know 9021 omg okay there this
podcast which i was also i was listening
to the podcast today
um and i do want to bring up really
quick because i'm fascinated about the
jane mansfield you were talking about
jane manfred man yeah okay because we're
i'm even more obsessed with you because
i feel like we're the same person
because i conflate this all the time so
jane mansfield died
in mariska hargitay's mom right yes and
she died really suddenly tragically in
an accident you guys were this i love
your podcast because you are talking
about 902-0 but then you go in tangents
that's you guys which is our dream to do
and they were like no we want it to be
about 90210 and we're like okay but as a
listener it's the pr it's like you're
talking about this and then you're
talking about chucky for 20 minutes and
then you're going back and i'm like this
is i just feel like i'm hanging out with
them yeah it's also funny to watch you
guys be like is that what happened what
was it like trying to remember this it's
so
endearing and charming and um and okay
so jane mansfield i'm obsessed with
celebrity dots
i think you're conflating it with
isadora duncan who was the dancer who
did have her scarf wrapped around her
neck and the scarf got stuck in the tire
and she choked exactly it september 14th
dancers
strangled in nice france when the
enormous silk scarf she was wearing gets
tangled in the rear hubcaps of her open
car she just strangled her yeah
bummer i didn't know scarves can do a
lot of damage i mean that's how kate
spade killed herself too and lauren
scott and loren scott that's right i'm
super like weird and superstitious and
uh i can't i can't wear kate spade now
such a bummer because i don't want
her
her business to go away just because you
know what i mean i almost want her to
get
it's my own thing her bathing suits were
really good though i
no no i don't know them i don't know she
had bathing suits yeah you can get them
on amazon they were actually really cute
but let me ask you something you just
feel like it's just there's an ookiness
like a creepiness yeah
you know her i know you know this but
i'm obsessed with these little things
that like i just found out that nicholas
cage was related to um
francis for coppola
what oh i did i i knew that and i was
like yep yep yep it's like what else do
i not know it's like i feel like i'm in
truman show and i'm like how like did
you and i'm running around to everyone
did you know
um uh who are we just talking about kate
oh jack spade
her husband is david spade's brother
right david spade is like the failure of
the family
which is so funny to me i love shit like
that like lisa kudrow's brother is the
um
great segway biggest migraine doctor in
the world
tell me
everything uh david kudrow yup right
uh went to him four month waitlist and
you have to have a journal don't you
have he wouldn't let me come until i'd
written a journal of my migraines
i was like dude these are basically
suicide no time ago okay yeah but i just
was staring at them not listening
thinking like do they look alike do they
not listen
yeah and but let me cuz migraines are
to me so important like when people have
migraines you have an understanding of
each other that like no one uh people
that don't get them will never
understand oh yeah bad headache you're
like no i feel closer to someone i've
never met that has migraines than like
the person i'm dating if they don't get
that hundred percent how do yours
manifest and how have you gotten control
of them
uh because i'm fascinated by this shit
okay so
i've gotten them for like 25 years
uh just my parents got them so it's
genetic it is genetic very genetic yeah
um got them on the set of 90210 the only
time in like 10 years i missed work
because i got such like my
behind my left eye my vision like
debilitating like i had to go home and
yeah devastated because i was like oh
they're going to be like oh the
producer's daughter's missing work like
no i couldn't function and it's like
it's a hospital with it
in the hospital wow they give you
morphine
dilaudid yeah i was on a list at cedars
because before i had like immatrics or
rail packs or any kind of way to like
know how to mitigate migraines i would
go into cedars with no health insurance
no money nothing and i would just like i
need morphine i can't see and that like
attic homeless addicts do that and then
you're on a list that's like do not give
this person morphine so i was on a list
at cedars that was like do not
administer sorry to god
to this person because i would just come
in they give me morphine and i wake up
like four days later and i i still owe
them quite a bit of money
so you just went to another borrower
yes there's a burbank er which i learned
if you're a migraine person you know
every in an animal person yeah you know
where every vet is and whatever whatev
where every er is yeah but i'm
fascinated because we both get migraines
i believe though that a lot of my
migraines like i'm now like on a birth
control that helps and i but i had to
cut out toxic people in my life because
a lot of my migraines were triggered by
adrenaline uh uh being caused by just
people that being around people that
stress me out or made me feel bad about
myself or made me anxious like i didn't
even realize that i was like being
friends with and dating people that
recreated my childhood circumstances as
an excuse to not talk to people i can't
call you back you give me migraines
i'm so sorry i've been told i wouldn't
be coming stop
won't let me talk to you you just like
because i can't have migraines i have
five kids i have work and it can't
happen and you give them to me do your
migraines get better after you had kids
a lot of people say that when i was
pregnant
i okay blinding migraines
when i was pregnant
initially and that's how i found out i
was pregnant once because i went into
the emergency room and i was like i have
a migraine i need salad can you do a
p-test i said no i said no don't worry i
just had a baby a month ago
um they said sorry we just have to do it
they did it and they came in it was like
days of our lives he was like excuse me
it was spelling uh
report you're pregnant i was like
impossible
i'm breastfeeding like i mean
oldest like myth in the book but uh they
were like well we'll do a blood test i'm
like do a blood test and then give me
the dilaudid but uh yeah i was pregnant
wild yeah was that the first time you
had sex since you had given birth yeah
what is the biological basis for that
why would our bodies do that
wait get pregnant or why would you want
to have sex
would you be able to get pregnant a
month after giving birth that is makes
me think that we are meant to just
be buried but yeah
we should not be in business
yeah i mean
we are meant to just makes me think like
all those times when i was younger and i
was like
oh my god i screwed up and i was on
birth control and then i was and i just
had a mistake like and then i thought oh
i can't get pregnant and then i was like
wow i just wasn't meant to be wow
yeah was there something kind of nice
about being like okay well at least i'll
be able to knock these two out like
two birds like i'm already i was
horrified i was like well i just did
this oh my god here we go again
yeah and then am i and tell me to cut
this out if you want i have ha i have
fake boobs am i going to be able to
breastfeed if i have kids
yes
but not they will have cancer
that doesn't happen either but um you
don't i don't think you produce as much
milk yeah
i've had them done three times because
they were it was like corrective and i
went to someone that was like by the
airport who had like
it was like oh my god my first ones were
at a strip mall a stripper recommended
them and i this doctor and i went and
they were just yeah whoa
yeah
airport strip yeah it was just so much i
was gonna say this is like actually yeah
it's got kind of shocking um that was
the first one that was the first one and
he cut through you guys probably he cut
through a muscle so i have a big like
and then uh a surgeon had to do two
surgeries to like get it back so i do
feel like i've been stabbed into so many
times that i have no milk dunk duds left
no milk that's left
i love me i love milk duds i mean really
chewy but like yeah you know what
there's so much time it's i can't
believe you just said that it's too
time-consuming yeah and you get a jaw
ache i would do it and then you're gonna
admire it and then you're and then
you're digging it out
and then you have to floss it's not you
know what it is it's not worth it no it
does aren't worth it
either blow jobs like it's the same
thing with the well it's just it gives
me a drake i yeah
do you read your read your audiobooks
yeah you have written what six books
yeah
how wild
it's crazy there's something just so
cool to me like what you came from in
the circumstance that you were dealt and
you're like i'm just gonna own all this
shit and write six books
they went hand in hand a little bit like
okay there's more books and you have
kids and that's wow saying one more one
more that's amazing well i have a
stepson so i do have six technical
i want to write a new one because i feel
like and yeah my editor was like oh i
don't know if there's any more to tell
i'm like there's stuff to tell daily
because i don't feel like it's like big
stories it's just like the everyday like
crazy shit that happens the people are
like oh it's a fun fun read i relate to
it i like your stories i also just think
there's so much um
i don't even think you realize how much
there's like wisdom that you kind of
just accidentally like throw i don't
even think you know you're doing it can
i tested wisdom and me
yeah
i don't know what you you've been
reading about yourself but i was
watching like um to come full circle see
you made me drink and here we are now
i'm on a team
so
watching you in interviews being like
yeah and the tabloids would you know
come after me and i was like this tablet
it was like it actually like i got a pit
in my stomach because i was like oh as
like someone that was watching you on tv
i didn't know that
it was like this weird oh it was like
you know what i'm saying it's like the
kind of thing when i'm like all these
people trashing me online like you
probably haven't seen it you're like
what do you mean you know and it's yeah
it's it's like
we see it the most like and and i was
just thinking about it i was like oh god
i feel this weird guilt about like
enjoying
her you know what i mean like it's okay
it's this yeah it's just this weird
thing where you're like had i known
like
or something it's so human though but
when you're like my experience with that
was just so different like what you did
like you're such a like like you know
like a martyr in a way you were giving
so many people so much joy and you were
having to suffer like it's just like
it's just so fun it just made me so
angry
i i mean i do the same thing by the way
like i'll be like i know this isn't true
about me and then i read something like
oh my god that happened to j-lo like
what happened and i believe it it's
human nature it is human nature and is
there what do you feel like because i
feel like now finally people whether
they have millions of followers or five
followers can relate to what like what
it's like to have something written
about you that is either not true or
hurtful and then have to see it like
you know
you never got the luxury really of just
having people gossip behind you at
school behind your back and you never
really heard about it right you were
none the wiser kind of thing but i feel
like you know what has been
like was there ever a moment for me it
was this for me it was
i
it only hurts me if i agree
that's where i am now i had to think
about that wow that's
i like that it only hurts me if i agree
so if someone's like your third special
you know your second special wasn't as
good as your third special i'm like fuck
that's true
that's the only time it really hurts
other times when it's like you're cunt
you're old you're busted
i try to go oh god i'm trying to think
how
bad my day would have to be for me to
write that to someone else to
anesthetize myself to have to like throw
like yeah say something that cruel
and then even when i do say something
like to say if i in if i'm frustrated or
something i'm excuse me ma'am i'll feel
so bad the rest of the day guilt yeah
kill and i'm like worse and like this
person
probably feels worse than i do because
they have to walk around with knowing
that they did that
have you ever done this though um
they'll write something mean and then
you write back
and then they're like oh my god you
responded i just i love you you're a
human being
and then i was like um okay yeah i never
do it but someone recently like i have
an email that is like my instagram email
and i check it like i have an assistant
like i read it and she was like you're
the ugliest fucking person i've ever
seen and just went on and on and on
and it like really fired me up and i was
like i found a million people call me
ugly like whatever
but this this woman really got to me and
so i wrote her back and i was like i'm
so sorry that you feel that way but i
just want to tell you you actually
really hurt my feelings and i have thick
skin and that that actually
i'm a hard-working mom like you said
you're a mom like it ruined my day
and then she wrote back oh my god
well i'm so sorry i was just trying to
tell you that you used to be beautiful
before you did all the plastic surgery
like she was trying it was like a
backhanded compliment if you're going
out of your way to hate me this much
percent of the time they just love you
and they're like how can i be different
yes i say like you're beautiful you're
amazing you're funny
what's the mental life hack so to me
when i see someone go your
your third special was so much better
than your second i go you watch two of
my specials
thank you okay
now i'm gonna i'm not gonna like now i'm
getting picky i'm asking you to watch
them you've watched too now i need you
to like them both equally now i'm being
unfair yeah okay okay fair enough you
know what this so it's like i always
like anything negative i'm like how do i
alchemize this to be a fucking positive
for me you know like if someone's like
it's like you used to be pretty like you
followed my whole career this whole time
you're my biggest fan
how do you get your brain to think like
that it is a uh
i'm a scientologist i'm kidding i have a
pamphlet i'd love for you to read i have
a pamphlet you're gonna love it and so
i think for me now it's like it's like
almost like exercising a muscle to see
an insult or something mean and turn it
into a compliment turn it into a
positive like where's the wind where's
the gift in this i mean i'm all for that
if my brain could do that but it's a
muscle like it's like it's like give me
any insulin insult me try to insult me
trying to hurt yeah give me one when
someone's like oh you're 39 and i'm
about to turn 39. like you're 39 and
alone i'm like
like that should be oh i didn't settle
you're right thank you that's so good
how can i mean it's probably like
delusional but it is i think uh a way do
you believe it i mean you you know how
to twist it now but do you actually
believe it um
yeah unless i agree with them
you do you know what i'm saying if
they're like you're alone and no one
would ever marry you i'm like
that's not true i have money plenty of
people could marry me right if they have
student loans it's in the back but like
how can that's like i think a form of
self-care is to like go how like i'm
just so curious because because you were
talking about it like was there ever a
moment that you like
the thick skin that you're talking about
when was it always sick was there a
moment that was like you know what fuck
it i'm gonna make this work for me was
it when you got the first check when it
was like of like oh
this shit's happening to me but i just
got paid for it so whatever small price
to pay like like wow no one has ever
asked me that and i actually don't know
the answer
um i can remember the first time it
happened by the way and it was like
obsessed with the person that goes i
don't know the answer let me think about
it
i don't know when it shifted it shifted
at some point i'm not going to say it
doesn't affect me it does sometimes
or maybe i'm just dead inside like i
don't know
thick skin dead inside is that the same
thing whatever
i'm obsessed with death becomes her
dude are they remaking it did i make
that up what i know i wanted to rewrite
that i wanted to do the remake
we can do our own after an ambien can we
do our ambulance well i wanted to do
like ambient become sir
becomes
uh the fridge made me do it like it ambi
like wait what uh and gray gardens like
i wanna like
blend those two emily and i are what we
what do you we call these eating little
leaves
we call each other big edie and little
lady yeah that is our life but so to me
it's like what's the win there's a win
in every in every moment yeah it's just
like and whether it's
i have no other option to think this way
or i've been in 12 step programs or
therapy or whatever it is like because
to me when i think of i was thinking
about you
um i was talking to emily about this
earlier and i was like what i think of
tori spelling like i think of like funny
i think of um
my favorite type of person like my
favorite type of person
that
and i i this i i hate saying this
because i feel like it sounds like
when someone that doesn't take
themselves too seriously like
that sounds i don't know why that sounds
weird maybe everything i'm saying to you
i'm worried is coming off wrong um no
but
i was just like i think resilience
that's what i think and resilience is a
skill and i'm just so curious if it's
something that's learned if something
that's inherent if it's something that's
practiced no
i'm like no no
no i'm just like
i don't give up i'm not a quitter like i
literally have been knocked down so many
times and i
i get knocked down
again yeah but what is that is that
sugar ray
can i remember that but if there's
something so
like effortless about it with you and
there's a buoyancy to it of like i'm
gonna make everything fucking work for
me i'm gonna cash in on everything like
any all of the pain where's my
cash do you get annoyed when people talk
about money with you or ask you
questions about it no
do you want to ask me a question about
money i don't think so like to me that's
the least you know i guess what i'm
realizing is that i was like to me no
offense but your family and the money
stuff is like the least interesting
thing about you is that insulting
no okay i actually love hearing that
because everyone says like oh the
inheritance your dad your mom like oh my
god can i tell you something like just
really quick if i could just go like a
tiny little rant because you said
something about like oh like i got yeah
i was like 90210 and then i saw somebody
like people accuse like of nepotism or
whatever it's like do you know how many
famous siblings
are a fucking it never happened to them
like what are you talk like google chet
hanks
okay do you know how many uh wait is
that his name chad hanks yeah he speaks
in patois and raps
he's do you know do you know this do you
know about him
what are we talking about this is taught
one of tom hanks's sons he has another
one
oh my god wait what
okay so just if you guys want to say
that nepotism is why anybody got
anything as if that's the only thing
that matters as if you don't have to be
talented i don't know what i'm looking
at ah okay this is
him i thought colin hanks oh
no colin hanks is a delight yes chet
hanks this one right here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like so it's just it that just drives me
so nuts because as someone that has like
known a lot of people in no wanna brag
uh known and dated a lot of people in
and out of uh
various rehabs in los angeles like
celebrity kids are not known for like
showing up and being able to fucking hit
something out of the park and create an
iconic character
you know so i just i was getting so
defensive and annoyed about that
um and yeah and then to me that's just
like the least interesting part of you
and i was like having you over i was
like is it okay if i don't ask her about
any of that kind of stuff i kind of just
wanna i just kind of want to talk to her
about animals and migraines and
boobs
oh yeah
so all the above so how many animals do
you currently have um i didn't know but
my friend counted and i have 29. 29
animals so
awesome
no i mean i animal control sometimes
listens to this podcast they found out i
was feeding my deer and they did show up
um are you kidding nope
because i do i am above the legal limit
but i am getting a kennel license well
that's the little loophole oh crap yeah
i know what am i gonna do that's i'll
help you okay i got it
so do you know of the 29 animals the
breakdown at all yeah of yeah yeah
how long do we have
mommy just
because you're one of the first people
through it when i had a wine okay go
during the wools of choirs i rescued a
pig i had no idea what i was signing up
for it was one of those like um abused
like starved like teacup pigs
that's the only way they stay small
there is no mini there is no teacup no
such because they starve them they
starve them and know that all over
instagram and like so people would buy
these little mini pigs that they saw on
instagram for five thousand dollars that
they thought were gonna be little pocket
like chihuahuas and then they go home
and feed them two cheerios and all of a
sudden they've got a pig in their house
i never have done that
was that what happened to you i mean
yeah
i've had many pig stories
my first pig i got
denise richards had pigs and they had
babies and so um
we had to give the pig back because it
shit it shit everywhere it used to spin
in circles and shit and spray and and it
was like a madness it was and it would
squeal it was horrific
and i was embarrassed so we had to give
the pig back and she took it back and a
lot of people don't understand pigs like
i love talking about this because they
are not like dog people like they're
like dogs no they're not no they're not
dogs sleep most of the time pigs have a
tremendous amount of energy they're
really emotional and they're very
territorial and they have to claim their
space and they're basically wearing high
heels so they're always like they think
they're just up all the time and they
piss in corners did you know this is
very glare witch yeah
it is it is
and
they um
uh root
they need to put they need to like root
their their faces in dirt and sh they
eat ass basically yeah and then um
uh they're very vocal and they bite i
don't want to say they bite because i
don't want to say that but they i have a
scarf yeah my pig bit me my pig yeah bit
busy phillips um uh
i just thought you said my pig bizzy
phillips and i was like oh my god that's
so cool you named your pig busy phillips
like that's kind of genius that's
actually my first boyfriend in la i'm
actually gonna call you out jared paul
brilliant brilliant writer he uh this
was maybe like 10 years ago we were
dating his dog was named jeffrey
katzenberg
i thought you were literally just
pushing your tips sometimes i do they're
so numb at this point so that picture is
the same really i have no idea mine are
like rocks you can touch them but are
they i mean not that you'd want to yeah
are these we need to be redone they're
expired
and recalled when okay
wait so when did you get these boobs
this is my second pair and that so
because you can only have them for 10
years at a time i didn't know that no
one told me that
you got to stop going to dr dre for your
surgery
um yeah so they've been recall because
you have to get them replaced every 10
years or something but mine were lemons
like the type of bag they used was
recalled and i thought my surgeon at the
time was trying to date me
um so he kept calling and i was like i'm
not gonna call him back not to calm back
no literally my mom set me up with him
and before after he did the surgery okay
so i met the surgeon because my dad's
doctor was also hugh hefner's doctor and
he was like okay you need to get yours
redone because you went to a mini mall
the first time right right and so he was
like you got your tits done at claire's
yeah basically like ear piercing and
some d's
and so he he took me over to the playboy
mansion and one of the playmates he was
like he just did hers she's gonna let
you feel them
i'm mouthing a surgeon and i'm like
blind and deaf what's not karth fisher
no oh oh the surgeon no no okay
i'm like no no no no that's a good mind
shout out garth you better give me a
discount next time i get my tit upgrade
for mentioning you wait can i get that
yeah okay totally half off
two for the price of one
um so i went to the playboy mansion like
got to go into her room and feel her
tits and she's like sure film i just got
them done i was like oh really soft
really great and i was like ah okay
uh
went to this doctor and uh
and yeah afterwards my mom was like oh i
think you know he likes you he's single
he would be a great dog he's touching
your boobs he looked like john goodman
but very nice guy
i was like oh not my type and then i'm
recovering at my mom's house wrapped up
and
she's like oh he's gonna come over and
you know do a follow-up checkup and have
dinner so we had like trays out on my
bed at the manor my mom's like this is
very boxing helena to me
i love that video
so romantic um
so yeah he was like sitting there and he
was like i would love to take you to
like the opera and i was like
and so yeah
anyway he was like can i can i call you
and i was like sure and so then yeah if
you like no couple months go by like he
did call me i didn't return his calls
and then finally i went in like
literally five years ago and he was like
i was like i just want to get him
checked out he was like you know back in
the day like we tried to get a hold of
you and i was like uh-huh
and he's like
those bags were recalled we needed you
to come in
and i was like oh man i thought you were
just trying to fuck me like it yeah
he's like why what probably i was but i
just while i you know before i
motorboated you i wanted to maybe yeah
he went home
now silly party we actually went hard as
rocks recalled expired but i need to get
them replaced so are they sick because
my first one my my first round of tits
were sailing and it thank you it
might look like a pair of alligator eyes
coming out of a pond
and you described that to me like they
like
they were so hard they were round and
hard oh thank you very much they were
round and hard
and
i could see the like like ziploc pucker
on the side that's the worst you could
like see the little puckering i mean
because i was also probably too skinny
too but and they were also why their
skin ruffles they're totally in they
were so wildly i know look like ruffles
like the chips you eat it too in the
morning on ambien and they were too far
apart so i couldn't even
like
like you know when you're like i have
new boobs i'm gonna let a guy like you
know have sex with my boot like i
couldn't even get him close enough
to like
they were so far apart i would like push
them so hard how small was his dick
like what do you mean sorry sir
that's just how that's how far apart
they were
like they were they were just like boom
they were like here do you know what i
mean they were just like they were they
were running away from each other going
in different directions they didn't get
along they were not a um they weren't
they weren't team players yeah and one
of them would get harder one of them
wouldn't and i also had these like
stitches that wouldn't come out
it oh no i had these stitches that
wouldn't come out and like two you
remember emily when i lied about i have
a picture of my first boobs you do do
you have them
remember you sent it to me first of all
emily was my assistant when i got my i i
got fake boobs and tried to keep it from
her
i was like go to go home and visit your
parents
whatever it was so weird because there
were so many way more embarrassing
things that she didn't care about but
a couple months ago you sent me a photo
of my first boob job oh remember
it looks it looks bad at that photo
you know i love this interview just as
much as you do but
we all need a little break
to talk about pills
because let's be honest
you're listening to two people who love
them
i want to talk about something
i have been passionate about
four years i have been so
innervated about birth control options
for women for years the rage i have
towards certain birth control pills
paid for this house
so we're gonna roll a little clip that
proves me right
brings me to a topic i'm very passionate
about which is birth control options
that are available to women i can't i
can't believe that we don't have better
options for birth control they all drive
me crazy what are you on
what are you taking
you have an iud come up here we're going
to take it out
[Applause]
i hate this product is yours plastic or
metal
yours is plastic okay well she's got a
mcdonald's toy in her body right now
[Applause]
most of them are metal some are plastic
most of them are a little piece of metal
they put inside your uterus i'm like i
don't want metal inside my body i don't
want to be
going through airport security
and having the guys behind the x-ray
machine like oh look at this slut coming
through
this bitch had to put a tin can up in
there
to stop all that sperm
no i don't want metal in my body what if
there's a storm
that was in 2016.
but i think i made my point
in that special okay and i have been
trying to make this point for years
which is why i am very excited not only
excited about this but also just
relieved that we have a new sponsor
called pill club where has this been my
whole life it's a birth control
subscription prescribed by a medical
professional and delivered straight to
your door for free
the pill club carries over 120 fda
approved brands most brands of birth
control are free with insurance or
medicaid otherwise prices start as low
as seven dollars a month without
insurance crazy the pill club delivers
birth control to your door for free in
discreet packaging so your neighbors
won't know you're bone-in
right now when you go to thepildclub.com
whitney the pill club is offering a 10
donation
to
bedsider.org for every good for you with
whitney cummings listener who becomes a
patient your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through
bedsider.org this is if you're a patient
without patience
pillclub.com
whitney after saying that now you know
why i shouldn't procreate get your first
birth control care package and donate to
help more women in need of affordable
birth control remember the pill club dot
com slash whitney you must use the link
to make a donation well i brought
everybody gifts
i wanted to make sure that you always
had magic spoon with you wherever you
went
so i made you this necklace and then i
made you one emily so you're not jealous
look at our magic spoon necklaces in
addition to being beautiful jewelry that
matches everything
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs in each serving only 140
calories in a serving
what revenge body much it's keto
friendly it's gluten free it's grain
free it's soy free and it's low carb
you can also
build your own box
available flavors to build your own very
own custom bundle
cocoa fruity which is my favorite
frosted peanut butter my new favorite
when i mix it with blueberry cinnamon is
a new one cookies and cream is new i
housed an entire box of it the other
night with no milk or anything um
and maple
waffle is the newest one for the
canadians i'm so sorry
and magic spoon just brought back two
super popular flavors
which is cookies and cream and maple
waffles
i got my emails
when these flavors were first introduced
for a limited time they sold out quickly
it's a guiltless midnight snack go to
magicspoon.com whitney to grab a custom
bundle of cereal and try today and be
sure to use our promo called whitney
checkout save five dollars on your first
order
oh i did drop it i'm here
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason well it is your fault it's on
you you should probably like take a look
at that call your dad telling me drop
the ball but they'll still refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com
whitney and use the code whitney to save
five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode and for everyone that is
sick of feeling guilty all the time not
just because of religion and their mom's
mistakes but also because of what they
eat go to magic spoon get it do it
i actually like uncircumcised penises i
i didn't
why i like it because
um there's something kind of like it
makes me go oh your mom didn't want to
hurt you
so i want to hurt
my three boys so even because then i
asked like the guy that i dated who had
no well i mean
a lot of people do it's like isn't it
now just more like a cleanliness thing
and uh
right i don't even know why we even do
it but there's like a medical safer for
stds safer for stds there you go because
that's what you're thinking about with a
newborn right yes like like safety is
clear it's also just kind of like a
um what's it called uh uh uh not a
protocol now i heard men have said like
oh it like
they don't have as much sensation down
there because it's circumcised
because there's a yeah i don't know okay
well how about you give me one orgasm
and we'll talk about sensation
how about you give me one orgasm in the
two years we've been together and we can
talk about you having sensation in your
dick
my my nipples are completely numb i
can't really feel anything from the
surgery here
oh i don't care i don't hard all the
time because i got them pierced
still
huh i mean
wait what
what
wait are they st are they still have
rings in them
yeah it's recent that's like a midlife
crisis you just got your nipples i did
where
in napa that's so fucking
punk rock
because everyone goes wine tasting in
napa and then it's like let me find a
place to pierce my nipples and that was
me
i was drunk
that is so cool it's kind of cool though
i was gonna say this is we're the
perfect people to join because it won't
hurt as bad probably
but you don't i didn't know this at
least they
are perma-hard like it i didn't know
that either that's not hard yeah a good
kids all the time are like we can see
your nipples and i'm like
yeah i hid them for a while and then one
time i like i was showering my son came
in i was like yeah one he's like
that's a nipple piercing cool you just
even like locked down you should have
been like no i'm iron man
don't mess with me
well then i went to this guy that like
changed them out and one's a bar
and one's like the hoop thing through it
and it looks like a fucking door
knockers like
that is so i hate it
you hate it the door knocks oh the bar i
like it can you change them yourself i
don't think so you have to go to
something to do it sounds scary yeah i
want to get back to the nipple piercing
because now i want them but since we
were talking about migraines i got these
piercings these days oh do you have them
these days piercings so it's um for
those of you guys listening it's like
the part of your ear that looks the most
like a clitoris like the the inside ish
part yeah uh i have piercings on both
sides yes and that help with my
migraines like
game changer because apparently this is
whatever the pressure point that
how bad
did it hurt
well i'm very good with pain me too
really good to me this was like it felt
more like pressure and like a pop
really yeah and the guy that did it
brian keith at uh body electric tattoo
same of course he fucks he he perfectly
goes like three two and he'll like do it
on two
so that you're not anticipating it it
hurts so bad like he did a lot of my
piercings and that one was like and he's
like oh because it's hitting like it's a
that's a good thing
mine is more
the after six months after sleeping on
it it takes this one this one up here in
the high cartilage took forever to heal
it still hurts
this i don't know but let me sleep at
night but i did really
well can you not i want to talk about
that because but what it did do
making bad news good news
always alchemizing negative things so i
had my ear bitten off by a dog it's been
sewn back on
and then and then i had my nose bitten
off by a parrot when yeah i don't know
long time ago
like when i was like 19. wha
was it were you shooting the show yeah
what happened uh
but you were telling a story i know
interrupted okay but we got to get back
to the parent
why do i hear about the dog okay so we
have like basically the same piercings
yeah so so i get the dog bite it it's a
dog that i'm rescuing it's not trying to
attack me it's just you know um you know
dogs when they're taken from their
mother too young they don't have manners
they're they're they're in a manner
their mom teaches them like you know
like like their mom teaches them their
teeth are sharp right so like the the
puppies will bite the mom and the mom
will fake like ah like it hurts more
than it does i know that so that they
know that their teeth are sharp so like
whenever you have a dog who has like a
nipping or mouthing issue you take their
lip and you put it under their teeth so
they can feel how sharp it is wow or you
exaggerate how much it hurts when they
do mouth you just scream and they go oh
no that hurts i'm not gonna do that
anymore i love this person okay
unless it's a dickhead and keeps doing
it and so um uh so we were playing it
was taken from his mom too young was
abused whatever ear comes up ears come
off real easily
cartilage is a joke
we are trash bags made of blood i mean
the fact that we get through life at all
is
when that how easily my ear came off i
was like how have i
survived any sex i've ever had like we
are so like it was wild how much it was
bleeding and how quick it's never been
fucking fucked in the air right like i
mean
we don't know i haven't but honestly i
can't believe that's not um
i would i need some new jokes i i
haven't been out lately i feel like guys
now
have really scaled it back after all the
the me too stuff they're scared
yeah everything's missionary now um but
it's a nice pendulum swing because
before that it was like everyone was so
high on porn they were like fish hooking
and jamming their fingers in your eyes
and like headbutting you
what is that it's when a guy is behind
you
and put the two fingers in your mouth
like this
from behind
why
you tell me
it's not good for him it's good enough
for you it's degrading it's degrading so
you're just like humiliating yeah you
feel humiliating yeah cause we need more
of that
right because i need more of that yeah
i'm like if you want to see me
humiliated like read my book
here i'll just hold my book right here
and you can just like read it while
you're fucking him
then i put in um the earrings right i
get all these piercings on one side
right and i'm like totally like have no
idea that it takes eight months for
these to heal and hurts so bad kills but
i feel like
it's why i started sleeping on my back i
sleep looking straight up and i'm able
to keep my product on my face the entire
night and it doesn't get on the pillow
because now i sleep on my back how do
you do this because obviously
for us women you're better today like
yeah you should always have a silver
silk pillowcase because we within like
three text exchanges got right into skin
we just got right into it it was less
than three i was like i'm obsessed with
you yeah so like hey you want to take
this text and you're like let's talk
skin not that i know
people tell me i have skin i don't know
i'm very neurotic about
good skin thank you
i will tell everyone everything i
fucking do because it is not natural i
was on accutane twice when i was 15 and
then again when i was 21. but then i
never i oh i wash my face like basically
with oil i try to just kind of never get
it completely wet
and i put my product on at night before
bed after i do a derma roller i sleep
with something called a sleep crown
which i put around my neck which is it's
almost like an airplane pillow but it's
like softer and like cold it's almost
like um you know those like weighted
blankets that are kind of cold that like
help you fall asleep and then i put on
noise canceling headphones on either
side of my head so that i don't hit the
pillow at all and i sleep straight up
like a vampire like that's a lot of work
i get up in the middle of the night and
what do i do in the middle of night when
i pee
oh sorry sorry besides that i reapply my
product what i'm peeing in the middle
and i i have it uh i have a separate oil
thing next to my toilet
you're making me feel real bad about my
holding it's a i mean
it's an illness or whatever but i just
didn't like that's just like a
habit when i was 22 everyone thought it
was everyone's always thought of lying
about my age and i look so much older
than i am that i just had to like figure
something out
hmm
what do you do with your skin i mean
and i work with beauty products so it's
like it's hard it's just consistency so
don't go on the sun your skin is like
like porcelain oh you do i mean no i
don't know can you wear sunscreen
no
you don't wear sunscreen
sometimes yeah why is your skin so
smooth do you like uh exfoliate it no
i think it's sleep
consistency and then the derma roller
the derma roller is a game changer i
have it i just can't the little prickles
the ones that makes little prickles
okay so the ones that makes little
prickles you're going to leave here with
so many derma rollers it's going to blow
your mind they're a little tiny it's a
roller that has little tiny prickles on
it it looks like a 50 shades of gray
sort of fucked up sex toy okay and you
roll it over so that um because so much
of our product doesn't even absorb
because we have so many dead skin cells
on the top that it makes little tiny
micro holes so that everything actually
absorbs it's changed my skin
changed my life okay i'm in
i want to because i'm so inspired by
after watching messiness
to admit some of the messiest shit that
i have done to you
that you've never told i
some of these i have not
seriously the fact that benton left
really pisses me off because i have to
tell the story alone i've done it
because there's something so liberating
about just telling everyone the
embarrassing shit you've done nobody can
fuck with you no one can get you if you
got if you're got yeah this is something
a story i have not told okay let me hear
you it's so bad it's so bad oh i love it
it's so bad okay
so
i'm
in the pandemic
um i should find the photo in the
pandemic you know everyone's doing like
ig lives like everyone's trying to
figure out like how to stay and you're
like hey hey what's up guy like it was
just no one could have any dignity
because we were all trying to figure out
how to like stay connected and relevant
and like engaged and entertaining and
like who the fuck are we without being
able to perform and god forbid us be
alone with our own thoughts yeah and so
i was doing like an ig live and it was
me and benton and i had i had had covet
i think
and i don't know i think i think i had a
covert fog for like two months like it's
all very murky and i couldn't take
painkillers because they make me um
nauseous so i was taking cannibals
i feel like i'm the only person who's
like should we be legal
i mean like after some of the shit i've
done on edibles i'm like should people
be able to just buy and get these
whenever they right it's intense yeah
someone like me should not um so i take
these uh
do you do wheat edibles or do you i have
weeds
work for you at all not really
no
um
you're ride or die dillon
that's not what i had when i froze my
eggs it was you froze your eggs i wish i
had done that really no well i can't
ever have a six now because i'm old as
fuck no you could number one you could
and you can have my ex how about that
you're like i'm gone thank you
i'm towards spelling
we don't want to fuck up the genetic
chain here
by the way the fact that you just passed
on my eggs is actually
you could have pretended you couldn't
like cool yeah
[Applause]
no thanks it looks like something's off
genetically here
i mean i think you're beautiful i think
you're smart i think you're funny
the dna helix feels a little sketchy i
don't know would you ever adopt i make
would you ever adopt
i don't know interesting that's really
honest right yeah i i i don't want to be
that person like
yes yeah like i don't know i mean i have
five kids like
can some would you ever drop one of
yours out
[Laughter]
i'm starting to think that that's what i
meant okay so go back to your story i oh
my god my extension's caught in my ring
i have this i'm putting this on ebay
give this to me wait
um so when i was oh my god you just
licked my hair
or whoever's hair this is yeah it's not
mine it's like
here's what is this this is mine do you
have clip in extensions i have
everything
those hurt my head those were migraines
like they were like you can't sleep on
them i'm speaking now i ripped them out
i have tape ins and clip-ins today
because i'm seeing you and i wanted to
look special
how what does your hair look like
without extensions it's short
yeah
have you ever colored your hair wild
colors
not like you really no i want to i have
temporary sprays okay let's do it wait
what color is that
you are in the host chair emily what
colors do we have wait can i just spray
the end yeah do it you want to let me
see
wait
what color is that spread oh i can't get
it i want it to be like it's tape what
is this oh this is uh
no no okay you're gonna tell a story
you've never told before i'm gonna tell
my embarrassing story but you brought
some animals with you oh my god you're
jumping to that to not tell the story
you weren't gonna finish the story i
will tell the story but i'm worried that
we have live animals she's in a tub
oh no that wasn't oh the instagram live
what was this it was an instagram okay
if we get to meet your animals if i tell
you the story i'll tell it okay okay
because you you are with
i mean you travel
with a posse of live animals i do
in a bag i mean in all fairness she told
me to bring them
i was like
okay
and um i okay so we're on i don't even
bathe my kids i paid my motherfucking
hedgehogs just to come see you i i feel
so bad that i was like saying it
facetiously and then you're like fine
and then
now i feel bad like i believe you i'm
all in
i'm obsessed with you okay it was fun so
we're on ig live and
oh god i've like as i'm even trying to
say it like i feel like a plume of like
dust is going to come out of my mouth
you know when you're doing ig live and
you're just doing it with people you
just pick random strangers to test you
yeah and you're just like picking them
and you're like hey it could go either
way like it's always a crap shoot like
and um we picked two we talked to them
and these two really sweet girls like
totally fine everything's great you know
whatever and as we're we're like okay
bye ig lives like people do record that
like they're you know there's like 20
000 people on this thing it was like an
ambush ig live right and you pick them
just based on their names and like a
photo comes up yeah and i'm with benton
i'm obviously dragging the story out
because i'm so scared to say what
happened it is not even that big of a
fucking deal so we pick two people and
then we're looking for the next person
to pick and i just say to benton oh pick
someone who's not white
what
in the ig like live
but i'm like
e like and then as soon as that happens
i get like my heart takes a shit because
i realize like oh this is filming like
it doesn't stop filming when you're
looking for the next person to we're
live we're street the hearts are going
up on the side i'm like pick someone
who's not white
and like
then the clown faces are coming up
sort of like a hook takes me all of a
sudden like my house just gets taken
away my car's getting
impounded they're just like relocating
me to the oak woods on borrow i'm like
i'm just my life's over
and i was like i was like i made so many
mistakes with the oakwoods um
and so but i was thinking about it and i
was like
and like i was like i've got it off and
like i freaked out i stood up
i hit i fell oh i was so freaked out
though no we have to i'd like get it
down
it's a post i will show you a photo
i was so high i tripped and fell and hit
that wall hit the side of my head
passed out like i had like i like
concussed myself i'll show you this
picture it is so wild and i like a giant
um
egg on my head but i was like for the
next like four or five days i was like
what if someone recorded that and
there's a video that's gonna be like
whitney
like
that's what we have to do sometimes it
was just no one wants to admit that
those are the conversations that are had
when you're trying to do the right thing
because everyone's like right you were
trying
everyone's like be inclusive be diverse
but you have to think and say things
like that in order to be diverse and
inclusive i just happen to say it out
loud and no one says it out loud
actually did nothing wrong
i was trying to do the right thing but
even when you're trying to do the right
thing
you have to pretend bullsh you know what
i'm saying it's like there's no one
posted this it was like at like midnight
it was like i don't maybe someone screen
recorded it and in like 10 years
ago when i'm in a custody battle um
those are my eggs
those are your eggs they're no they've
been given to you those are
you've got you've got them for you've
got a two year lease on them i have 16
eggs in redondo beach which means one
out of every four is going to have down
syndrome so you probably have 12.
they threw out two that had down
syndrome that they pulled right away
after they gave me so much past well
like right away when they pull it
they're like no these are duds like they
knew right away but they gave me so much
fentanyl i'm like that's probably why
you just like hot me up on fennel what's
fentanyl fentanyl is what i think
michael jackson died uh fentanyl is a
painkiller that wears off it's like a
complete orgasmic sedative but then
it'll wear off in like five minutes can
i tell fentanyl is like i mean that i
get why michael when i first had
fentanyl i was like michael
respect hats off like you actually lived
way longer than you should have wait i
thought it was uh am i getting wrong
propofol fentanyl
propofol laced with fentanyl
sounds amazing i mean i'm just gonna
have to figure out a like a like a
workaround to win this it feels like
something was laced with something
and then um uh yeah my eggs are there i
was about to freeze embryos
um but i don't think that's gonna happen
right away because freezing embryos you
have a higher chance of actually
conceiving later
if it's frozen embryos
should i i am so afraid of giving birth
and women do it all the time why am i so
scared
because you're overthinking it you
weren't like
this doesn't mathematically work
no i was like scared but psyched to push
and then i was in like 17 hours of labor
poop
no because no i i thought everyone
pooped well i didn't and it was a
c-section
and they were like emergency c-section
we're going now and i was like
i freaked out i had done lamaze all that
shit and like yeah
why did they do it because there was
like something his heart rate dropped
and like he was like they were like we
gotta get him out now like her vagina is
too perfect we can't ruin it well now
that we see it
i mean my ob gyn did say it's like a 13
year old's but
how did he know that's what 18 year olds
were not appropriate on any level
for him or myself
[Laughter]
a friend of mine got the vaginal
rejuvenation surgery because she tore
eight inches total eight she didn't
she's but in three places so she tore
a bunch of i mean the baby like walked
out like a smiley face yeah it was it
was and she went to get the rejuvenation
and the doctor said to her do you want
to go back to 16 18 or 21 size wise and
she was like
what do you think happens between 16
like
it was such a speci so specific
that's ridiculous it was like something
that was like just so like what do you
think happens between 18 and 21 in terms
of your vaginal side like he just had
some it's so interesting a friend of
mine um
uh uh her gynecologist told her the
story about how i'm
about the husband's stitch yeah
you know the ones the one like sort of
stitch or whatever and there's this um
uh the gynecologist is this woman and
after a friend of ours gave birth the
husband came over
and was like hey so can you
you know he asked he literally said like
you know
he literally said can you like put the
stitch in it and the
every time she says it happens all the
time and then she just says the husband
how small do you need it
that's a big one oh which is like
the perfect thing to say like how tiny
do you need it big boy
and you're like
i'm good my sister uh in law she got her
first with cesarean and then
i guess now just the technology is
better you can get them more i would
just schedule a cesarean am i allowed to
say that
i mean i would just be like i'm good i
just like let's just pull it out the
old-fashioned way through the stomach
like aliens sigourney weaver so i'm so
weird everyone's like you've had so much
plastic surgery i've really have not
don't get me started but i know i know
but when i look exactly
people are like
i'm like no i had an emergency one that
i tried didn't couldn't do a v back he
said i wouldn't dilate how about this
i'm so fucking nervous i should just be
like fuck you i have five c-sections if
you accuse me of having plastic surgery
which i get all the time i'm now the
point where i'm like
thank you for thinking a skilled
professional put this together that's
all they're saying what they're really
saying like you've had plastic surgery
they're like this must
come from a school of perfect someone
someone who studied perfection must have
crafted and sculpted this because that's
how perfect you are i don't think
they're saying that about but that is
it because if they can't handle the fact
that you look a certain way without
medical intervention that's them going
like well i could totally look like that
too if only i had surgery like that's
their way of making themselves feel
better when have you ever criticized
someone else not to make yourself feel
better that's why we do it i guess so
but what really riles me up is like i
went years without like doing little
maintenance because i was so bothered
that people said i had plastic surgery
when i had my nose done and i was like i
had nothing else on my face you had your
nose on my botox and i was like but i
was so bummed i was like waiting waiting
and now i'm fucking falling apart okay
well i'm like shit well and you didn't
even do it right you got your nose done
by a parrot
yeah i mean you get your nose down and
then a pair of bites at all shin health
matters it was already fucking botched
but it's just like to me that's just
like the tax for being
you know it's funny like i realized
something and you've without knowing it
have like helped me with this
uh because you lean into
your humanity and inevitable
um
shit like this you know what i'm saying
like and
for me like i spent so much time trying
to pretend for 10 pretend i was
something someone that i wasn't it's
like i realize like you know
i'm triggering to people
i am and i'm not trying to get sympathy
i'm not i i am there i know
that there is a why
why do you think
without self-aggrandizing or or bragging
or being a narcissist we all know my
self-esteem is abysmal um
i got success young right i was i was a
woman in a male dominated field i'm loud
i'm fucking shrill i'm everyone's uh
mom that yelled at them and punished
them so if a guy
doesn't have a chance to have sex with
you and you're and you're doing this
like
they hate you know it's right i was
thinking about this the other day
because i was like you know whenever a
guy's like yeah you're pretty funny and
i'm like like the idea that a man would
come watch pay money to watch a woman
talk for an hour
this nasal and shrill
with no chance of fucking them at the
end
that is like
the most feminist man
on the of all time like now when like
guys are coming to my shows and they're
not laughing at every joke hysterically
i'm still like dude
i love you so much for being here
because there's no like you're here yes
you're just listening to a woman like
basically attack men and complain and
make fun of you and you're paying me
money and then and laughing like so i
think for me i also realized i was like
i have this astronomical expectation of
like how everyone needs to like me all
the time and that's not honoring
people's like childhood traumas people's
insecurities we need the same reason
sometimes we need a glass of wine to
unwind hate and negativity and criticism
those are a lot of people's coping
mechanisms and drugs you know i know
that when i first
i've never
criticized more people about being
unfunny
than when i was unfunny
that was not funny that's right no i was
like i'm not
right it's like and when i actually was
funny i never said that about anybody
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah it's
like no one that's right with themselves
and is is full needs to do that so when
someone yeah when someone as someone
that yes as someone that has
used edibles to cope as someone that has
used love and sex in relationships and
work to cope as drugs
you know when someone
comments like you're fucking busted
whore you're not funny i have written
this back to people and i'm not being
sarcastic i literally will go i
genuinely hope that worked like i
genuinely hope that
helped you get through your day
and what is the response
usually it's oh my god i never thought
you were gonna see this and it's shame
and it's whatever which is like
bless your heart or it's nothing
and it's like oh if you're because to me
i'm signing who the fuck says you're
busted you say bust it a lot i know
that's the trigger word their word's not
mine busted i get that a lot busted yeah
busted you're busted what is busted
you're
can we do it like a trailer of her what
is fush hooking what is busted
i'm learning so much tonight but it
busted is like just a guy saying that a
woman is
aging broken broken older like like oh
your face is busted yeah i mean yeah i
sleep by the way i sleep two hours a
night like
life is really shy like i would
yeah i i should be that i earned these i
earned these wrinkles like i earned
these crow's feet
you know but i also um yeah i get so
fucking angry about that because
where where people get triggered about
plastic surgery is so interesting and i
think there is a biological basis for it
it is like a you know people like women
like you're tricky you're you're i think
it's rooted in men's fear
of being with a hooker and then finding
out that it's a like trans woman or
something that's like you're tricking me
you're tricking it's all about that it's
like yeah my hair is clipped in my
eyelashes are made of tupperware
synthetic i don't know what this is i
have lip liner nine feet around my lips
it's like you know what i'm saying i'm
wearing i'm wearing purple powder my
eyeliner is i'm i literally have crayola
all over my face i'm wearing self tanner
i use teeth whitening gel
and you draw the line at
botox like where
now i'm fake i feel like women say it
more to me it's not bad yeah you're
right you're women that are more
attacking but it makes them feel better
at least it makes me feel better though
think about like when i see a woman with
a huge butt i'm like oh her butt's fake
that makes me feel better
same do you know what i'm saying so it's
like if people are using us
to feel better it's like i signed up to
make people feel better to make them
laugh to make them like
if you need to hate me to feel better
like how to maybe it's not
up to me to choose how i make you feel
better maybe liking me is one way i can
make you feel better make me laugh and
then hating me is another way i can feel
better like maybe that's why i'm going
to be of service of you today to you
today
wow
yes
if you need to hate me to get through
the day is the new entertainment it's a
new like
we just made people's lives right i'm
polarizing you know people hate me or
love me that's it
there's no that's sweet the best fucking
place to be my thing is this i would
rather you fucking hate me than like
kind of like
feel nothing
because yeah or just be no you don't
want to be that you don't that's
fantastic i would rather be
i just want to get some i signed up to
get some kind of reaction yeah from
people and if it's like or hate i don't
i can't really control that like that no
that's like has to do with your
parenting in your childhood whether you
like me or don't like me like
either i i look like your mom and sound
like your mom or i don't that's what it
boils down to you know
wow
and if you don't like me like that's
also that's also your business like if i
like me if you don't like me like
i'm good but that's like the howard
stern motto right
like all like what was the percentage of
his listeners they hate him but they're
like
yeah and you know what else it is
it's like
you know i remember one time i was in um
i was at the comedy store and i was like
doing this new bit and it was doing
really well and there's one guy in the
front row which by the way i'll project
all day long like he didn't think it was
funny he didn't like me he was like
didn't he was probably drunk who fucking
we never know what's going on with
people like
someone that dm's you and is like that
woman her dad could have just died she
could be off her men
who knows what was going on in her life
who cares but um uh like she sucks not
defending her i'm like why don't you
bully her in first
right no no i know i know
like compassion for like you get to be
you like at the end of the day she has
to be her and you get to fucking be you
and um but uh oh yeah so there's one guy
at the front and as a comic it's like
all i could fucking focus on was that
one guy that wasn't laughing and i
eric andre was in the room and he
actually like we were laughing about
afterwards because i stopped you and i
was like
okay sir so
you're not laughing so are you saying
everyone in here is wrong
like you're not only insulting me but
you're saying
insulting everyone in here yeah like
what how
how is it possible that you're right
like what are the chances
that you're right and everyone else here
that's involuntarily laughing is wrong
and i realized like that was just my ego
and my insecurity but it was like oh i
get to choose what i focus on like i can
focus on this one person
and cut myself emotionally what did he
say because then i was like oh i'm doing
this damage
you're not you're just existing and
moving through life and i'm
i'm hurting myself i'm using you to hurt
myself i'm choosing to hurt myself with
you you just happen to be here you're
nothing you're meaningless like i could
focus on everybody else that's laughing
in the past but you yeah but that's so
human i would do you know when you like
go through tweets and people like i love
you i'm obsessed with you i'm upset and
you just scroll right past them
what the fuck is that one why don't you
why don't you write back the people that
say i love you so much you changed my
life and like we don't care about them
you're right isn't it we do we do care
about care but we're not like it doesn't
make our day the way one negative one
ruins our day they don't have equal
weight it's not the same
most of it is positive
you know what i'm learning here today
that i need a lot more therapy
no i really do like i really have not
evolved i really need help and that is
not true you are you have you are
and then we're gonna get to your service
animals you are
when i say like
i'm also so excited for your kids
because i feel like what i saw don't be
i mean
i love frozen meals
wait
that's
normal okay that's how normal kids eat
all kids eat that shit it's good it
preserves them they're embalmed healthy
foods not good for kids they need
chemicals
to preserve everything
formaldehyde oh dude i literally only
ate red number five growing up people
like you have such good skin i was like
i think it's because i only ate dr
pepper until i was like 12. i drank out
of a hose
it's my favorite is diet dr pepper i
have an entire fridge full of it we now
take a little break from talking to the
gorgeous hilarious tory spelling to
talking about article furniture my
favorite thing to collapse on when i get
the vapors
you know what
actions speak louder than words and i
know that probably sounded like it came
out of nowhere
but it didn't
so instead of just telling you how much
we love article because we do it every
week we thought we would just show you
how easy it is to receive unpack and
assemble
article
furniture hit it
[Music]
our
article furniture is so
article
article furniture is so easy to assemble
that i can do it myself
see
that's all it took
now let's lay it out sir
oh beautiful
spank my butt
oh that was supposed to be flirty and
sexy there's a giant light beam coming
off the laser it looks like a lightsaber
in the video did you think this was a
laser you called this a laser did you
think this was a laser beam what do you
think that that is well what is it a
screwdriver
whatever this is a light table it's just
like not a laser beam they call it a
drill
it slices things up it's an ex-boyfriend
uh lock opener
like ex-boyfriend's apartment lock
opener yeah it's called an impact driver
look at that
our beautiful news is that not flirty
and fun no that's great that was uh
abuse uh the new beautiful article
ottoman that i just bought no matter how
you pose on it it's classy i can pose
like this i can pose like this i can
post like this
or this or this
thanks article for keeping me classy
oh our last article ad
[Music]
but luckily there's so much stuff in the
background look at other sponsors our
last article
by the way that was our last article but
that looks like the first ad
ever shot
we shot the first ad ever article is the
easiest way to make your space look
beautiful fast affordable shipping is
available across the usa and canada and
it's free on orders of over 999
hot model in a mini dress with horses on
from amazon not included
i did stutter but you get it it was
funny article is offering our listeners
50 off your first purchase of 100
or more go to article.com
whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout it's
like they make everything so freaking
easy that's article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
purchase of 100
or more go to article furniture if you
want your house to look like everything
you see in my house on instagram because
it is all from articles
that's great i don't know about you guys
and gals ladies and worms
but
i really put off going to the doctor
during the pandemic as you can tell by
my appearance
uh and limp
but it is time for me to get back on
track okay i'm i'm sick of just brushing
one side of my teeth you know because
the other ones are too sensitive i feel
like i'm going to start going to the
doctor again i feel like
that clicking sound
i feel like we can lube oil that up
somewhere yeah let's clear that gout up
don't you think
can you please call dr kevorkian and
make an appointment grace
oh my god what
are you horrified because i'm horrified
because he's dead because he's a killer
no because who calls the doctor's office
to make a doctor's appointment anymore
is that what you do for a living
okay touche but no
what
you would know that i'm never on the
phone because i just downloaded the free
zok doc app the easiest way to find a
great doctor and instantly book an
appointment with doc doc you can search
for local doctors who take your
no no no no no no no no
no no no she's very young she doesn't
understand in my day you just walked
outside and just were like is anyone a
doctor right like on a plane no if
you've ever been seen by a real doctor
like a board certified well no i see i
see real doctors the ones that like have
you just come over to their house nicely
dead people
are working
i'm just saying i'm just saying like
when you the i don't know what you're
talking about here but in my day to get
a doctor moment you have to call
between you have about three hours of a
day you can't call you call between 9 30
and and 10 15 and then wait for lunch
and then there's a lunch break right and
then you get the voicemail
and then at like two you have about 2 45
to 4 15 you have a window and maybe
they'll call you back maybe maybe maybe
or you'll call them like can we put you
on hold and you're like nothing and they
put you on hold and then you just die of
whatever thing you have
is that not what sort of rigmarole
and then you just pray they take your
insurance once you get there oh no they
won't though right you can pray but
right right right that's why i learned
how to be my own doctor forget it okay
well that's why you all need zoc doc
where you can check if the local doctor
takes your insurance read verified
patient reviews and book an appointment
in person or on video right through the
app and it's all free never wait on hold
with the receptionist again whether you
need a primary care physician a dentist
a dermatologist a psychiatrist an eye
doctor or any other specialist sock doc
has you covered whoa whoa
whoa whoa yes so this is like hinge for
doctors yes exactly
oh yeah you scroll through you see a
little picture of them you see like
where their office is you can't read the
reviews i was gonna say is there a
dating app for just doctors
farmers only but for doctors doctors
only doctors the problem is they
wouldn't let us off 100
laughter laughter's the best medicine
you'd be impatient sometimes
patience only
okay so so grace uh i'm so thrilled that
this exists zocdoc i'm so thrilled you
all
have it
you can be released yeah it sounds like
you don't even discuss it anymore
this is literally
what i need help with the most is
calling doctors and trying to make an
appointment because it is a full-time
job
especially if you have as many you have
eaten as much mercury as i have yeah you
have a specialist for things i didn't
even know existed
what
what's rheumatology
really that
a riddle of riddle college
she helps me write jokes yeah
[Applause]
want to just let how all of you have
used this service yeah actually
i had a hot gyno um actually i was
getting a pap smear while i was texting
you the other day with my zoc doc okay
but i'm just saying how easy it is for
you to get an appointment yeah i
actually do this this is how i found all
of my doctors same same same and i love
them all wow yeah that's crazy it was so
easy i heard about it from great this
makes me angry it's like when you it's
like um
like when you find out i'm like talking
about the slot on stage right now like
when we used to take temperatures with a
thermometer but you're you just have
your generation just has a little gun
and we had it in our butts that's it
just makes me kind of angry when i find
out sometimes how easy things are now
it's that mean i'm getting old i'm going
to need more sock docs
i need a lot more dogs
go to zocdoc.com you know what
i need to go to right now to go to an
eye doctor because i can't read what's
on the screen i believe it's go to
zocdoc.com
whitney and download the zoc doc app to
sign up for free every month millions of
people use
zoc doc and i am now
one of them it's my go-to whenever i
need to see a doctor which is
no
all the time sock doc makes health care
easy and now is the time to prioritize
your health
again
go to zocdoc.com
whitney download the zockdoc app to sign
up for free and book a top rated doctor
many are available as soon as today
whoa i have so many weird moles
that sockdoc.com
whitney that z-o-c-d-o-c
dot com slash whitney this is the
meanest thing i'll ever say to you do it
we are so similar
it's like
compliment
the fact that you fuck with diet dr
pepper just made me so obsessed with you
oh it's my jam
i don't drink water you probably didn't
have this as a kid
i never drink water
i hate it i have to do crystal light
look at my water i have to put crystal
light in it and then you still like
their like glasses collect
so they're everywhere i look at all
these beverages i have that i don't look
at my water i was noticing this one this
is why i do i have never
known but the wine i finished the wine
done the wine
the kombucha empty bottle empty there is
water in here though it counts you're
different you have been on television
most of your life
you went from film to high def i wish
that on no one oh
tell me about it that is a type of
trauma that most women will never half
you went from film to high deft now i
like look at these filters on instagram
and i walk into my dermatologist let me
give me that yeah
i said am i the only one he's like no
everyone can i tell you but also there
is this very specific trauma of uh my
niece i guess started watching friends
this is going to come off wrong but
that's my brand
i'm just going to say it with my heart
in the right place and hope that it
comes off right
which is uh uh so friends is like on
netflix now and like new generations are
like finding it i mean who's like 12 who
um
like loves friends and it's like oh my
god do you know jenny
and she like
went to jenna anderson's like page it
was like wait is that rachel
and it's like oh yeah she's not she's
that was shot 25 years ago
like she was like oh
she's and it's not i mean jen looks the
same age which is so wild when you're
known
you can't fucking age it's like when
people like like you know cameron diaz
like got old it's like no you just
watched one of her movies last week when
she was 20
and this is just how old she actually is
now like it's such a fucked up thing so
our parents all said it and we didn't
get it and now it's happening to our
generation like we're seeing people age
we're like
and it's everyone's like like young
people to take selfies all the time like
you're not gonna like that in 20 years
you want to get that off the cloud like
it is this now we constantly summer our
generation are like our parents they
didn't have photos of themselves from 15
years ago on the internet all the time
like we i catfish people every day by
accident like i'll go what do you mean
what i'm just saying it's like if you
google me and i show up you're gonna be
like i don't know what photos you
googled i don't know what you saw if you
google me shit's gonna come up from 10
years ago that's not what i'm i have
different tits i have a different ass i
have my eyebrows like it's a different
blonde thank you
i um i'm so co-dependent want to be
friends with you that i will stay blonde
for you if you like it
but
i do have to go back to pretend at some
point because i am fully balding i mean
i'm balding but i do like to um
i like to be blonde so i can stretch
okay let's do it okay wait what are you
doing um
you wanna you decide what color my hair
is green and then i wanna meet your um
animals oh you want me to do powder blue
i know what what that's what this this
is powder blue
this is these are the hair sprays that i
now will because i can't i watched you
got go uh tennis ball yellow i did
because here's the other thing i liked
it isn't it amazing when women have fun
people have to say they're a mess oh are
you doing this wait no well what are you
doing i'm worried that you're wait this
is temporary though this will wash out
but if you how long how are your hair
extensions real or these like jessica
simpson here
is this from a human head of course oh
wow okay so you're going to be really
stupid
right well i've had that pay for it i
don't okay so this is peach okay this is
oh my we're fully trying to do peach or
blue i don't know whatever will make you
like me the most
do you like i like the peach is kind of
weird we do have similar skin tones
orange is weird on us this is an orange
and i i do it very sparingly what about
neon i've never done neon green i'm not
doing that okay that's like slimer shit
it is i feel like you've this is like
ptsd from like nickelodeon awards like
goo
i feel like you've had to
live through that should i do it or
you're doing it i'll you do it then i'll
match you
you're just
i like the blue
it's like a powder blue right
isn't it kind of cute it matches your
shirt
isn't that good
yeah and it's just like right at the
ends and it washes right off isn't that
fun i guess it'll wash off yeah you
should um do this on your messiness on
mtv like every episode or every like do
a different little
color at the end okay now
she's really oh it's getting too blue
no it's not cool
the way you did it it's like very like
mermaidy and like ombre
i think it's cool i'll do it to match
see hold on that's on your right side
i mean i can't see anything
whoa what
go to bed it's spotty
what do you mean that's not good oh no
is that not how i should do it is that
good like you're feeding my initials
into your head yes
oh my god oh my god oh my god wait wait
wait wait wait
okay but on this side because this one
hold it down okay blank okay
don't move your fingers so cold
it fucking says ts i'm obsessed i'm
taking a picture of that you fucking
you guys
is it not
right there do you see it ts for life
bitch
wait now you're moving it oh you fucked
my shit up i like had it perfect
shit but now we've doing hairspray on it
so it's saying yes it's yeah i marked
you i've been printed on you i twilight
your shit my dream okay
did you get it i don't i'm afraid i'm
gonna move it yeah why not my hair is so
thin and wispy at this point that if i
may want a little more of it oh my god
now in the tea
i mean let's be a fairy you she is
territorial
[Laughter]
oh my god it's so cold
and now i wrote dick okay let's go next
what's next
i'm so aggressive
once you're like
no one commits quite like tori spelling
um i know i have to let you go and i
hedgehogs
what
so tori spelling in addition to being
hilarious dazzling resilient prolific
honest
like iconic legendary star
has hedgehogs
but i was scared to show them are they
illegal
a lot of things we've done today are
illegal yeah okay so i was like do i
have to say they're rescues or they're
just like vintage
or like because that clears everything
up you say like hey that was vintage
like it's vintage it's okay it's okay to
have it am i wrong
yes i try to only buy leather if it's
vintage it's like the thing's been dead
for 40 years same you know what i'm
saying and it's just you know
but yes that's a whole thing okay so
i've never seen a hedgehog i have albino
ones i've never touched a hedgehog i
don't i'm like like this is because that
story you told when you're like get
someone white on here i brought you
albinos they're white hedgehogs vanilla
thank god that wasn't open okay okay so
i told her have gloves ready
oh no they're good
i think they're dead
this one
chic yeah oh my god these are my pink
gardening gloves oh they hit some prick
okay that is a stuffed animal okay okay
this one's fake to be fair
there is a fake hedgehog in here and i
was like that
if she thinks
well first of all i saw the fake
hedgehog and i was like oh no one's told
tori spelling that that's a stuffed
animal
i was like this i was like
i was like this is what happens to
really really famous people is they
don't know the truth anymore and i'm
gonna have to spring it on her that
that's how they pooped in people from
ephesus you know i paid them right
before we came here that's a lie my
daughter oh they're do they shake oh my
they hiss but um once you have them
guys are they there's two hedgehogs in
here i brought a towel just in case i
don't care about piss i don't care about
shit are they
do they like people no
okay
is this an upsetting experience for them
there's a hamburger in here what do they
eat
cat food
whoa should i do two gloves
honeys
oh
under the belly hi baby wait that'll
hurt you want to put your other glove on
okay okay sorry
oh my god
what's this one's name
uh hedgehog one
okay so they don't have names no not yet
hi sweetie
hi
i'm certain i'm scared it's gonna stab
your tit i love you the little nose the
nose pop my boobie if you want
hi
do we know what they like or what they
value
no
hi little guy how old are they
babies
like four months okay look at the little
nose oh my god little red eyes oh my god
it's so cute
like if you put it down it'll like be
fine how big do they get this is it
they're gonna just be this big forever
i mean
sorry baby
hold on hedgehog i thought you were
giving it wine wait i don't have wine
oh oh okay hold on hedgehog number one
here
oh thanks okay i'll be much more relaxed
we're swapping hi baby
oh you are heaven
hold on oh my god you're the animal
whisperer wait it's never this calm
really this is like shit at me
i can't believe you're doing this oh my
god pink suede gloves hi how's it going
wait what they usually like cover them
like it likes you this is weird do you
want it
yes
no
no yeah trading my eggs for this
hedgehog
i mean i just want your eggs hi
sweetheart
this one hates me this is the bigger one
you know what i'm realizing
if you hold them in their belly oh i
didn't get all the poop out of the head
well
we try you you wash them with a
toothbrush
oh wow yeah how often do you wash them i
don't know hi little bud
once
oh
oh it's hissing yeah it's okay that's a
hissing you're allowed to hiss if you
want okay
you can hiss if you want
do you want to walk around would you
want to hang do they like to be petted
no
that's hissing yeah okay
you're allowed to hiss i'm a stranger
why wouldn't you and then see when it's
normal it's just like walking around and
do they are they related
yes brothers okay so they know each
other but they don't necessarily like
each other they're not necessarily
social
no they do
do they like to socialize do you like to
with each other yeah if you put it down
like look this one's oops sorry
imagine if you were just like
i like that you make sure that every
animal in your life has the same hair
color as you
hi buddy do you want to walk around no
you want to stay
hit real oh see it goes down okay
it's so cool how it goes down oh hi baby
so wait they don't have names should we
name them yeah do it how do you normally
name the way you name your children
really fascinates me
why because they're just so timeless and
and
unique but not
trying really hard to be timeless and
unique oh thank you that makes sense
like really no fruit names like it was
just yeah classic not obnoxious not like
no um
uh
grammatical symbols that aren't on
computers like no accents like you're
not trying to make people feel stupid or
like it's just i'm obsessed with you do
you want to hide in there yeah what
about like
what's your favorite movie
oh
splendor in the grass
natalie wood oh wow and billy madison
billy and madison
and death become sir oh that's right we
could do
match and the other one oh no but
they're boys why do they have to be
named boy names what's a boy name even
mean nothing they could be anything
what about
hmm
you are prickly you're a prickly boy
um
look how cute could it be something it's
good you can hiss
you're allowed to have feelings
you're allowed to have feelings you're
tiny and vulnerable
what are some things we can name them
that would be like
good reminders of um
abercrombie fitch
what do you want well is there anything
that's like
because this is interesting because
these are animals that are so vulnerable
that they have to have like big
like sharp
exteriors exoskeletons to protect
themselves and we had to do that you had
to develop a sharp prickly exoskeleton
maybe to protect yourself
but you guys don't need it anymore
you're not in danger you don't need all
these prickles because we're not you
don't need to hit so i'm not going to
hurt you
is there anything that's like symbolic
about like the war being over and not
needing all your pricks anymore
sorry i just kill it
um
let's bring his head down
hi guys
they're so sweet what's better than the
joy of just watching an animal do
nothing nothing it's the greatest this
is my like choking on my extension here
he's curled up
that's fat
a bat
that's bad like when he's curled up he's
putting all his spikes out well that's
okay i think he looks like he's like a
ball and he's like yeah yeah
like how um like an ostrich puts his
head in the sand yeah
how about whispering an angel
my favorite one
jim jim beam and uh
jim beam and sam adams
dr
pepper
dr pepper i always feel like you have to
name animals things that they are
lacking so if a like a horse is lacking
pride you name him like king or queen
um
they're scared they
how about like
oh who's brave like
what's a fucking nut
but you don't want they'll feel and
busted you say those words a lot that's
so true
hi guys they're eyeballs allergies i
feel like i'm allergic to them their
eyeballs look like caviar
like little caviar
do not suck out their eyeballs i love
caviar yeah i don't think i've ever had
it what
okay i don't think i've ever had caviar
what does it taste like it's like salty
yumminess
like pussy and it's gross yeah but i
like caviar
tastes like pussy you heard it here
first
this is my favorite episode
this is my favorite episode of anything
ever recorded
of any show ever recorded i just had a
liar
hi mr man
i see you don't go down
but they don't you're not worried
they're gonna like run off the table
they don't they don't scurry
they just kick it not that i'm aware of
what's their purpose in nature now that
i see them i don't know like what are
they it's sad it's sad like what's the
point they as cute as they are
what yeah
right i'm not sure what purpose they
serve look at when they have them brush
back and they're just looking they're so
adorable they're like little mo they
have little mohawks that one loves you
yeah oh my god i've never seen it like
this
oh hi it has a face i never knew that
this is actually like a wild metaphor
for all of our negative dms it's like
are they mean are they just scared
yeah i'm just scared well cause i just
came at you hard i'm sorry
yeah
see there's mama there's mama what do
you think of mama
i mean these things they look fake
but they don't bite nope
do you have friends that have hedgehogs
no
you've never you know anyone's had one
and
and you
have no idea how they evolve like what
do they get night as they get older they
get more comfortable with you
i've watched videos i can't do it though
they like smooth them you have to
socialize them a lot i think with each
other with yourself like you have to
hang out with them a lot yeah oh it's
okay
because honestly they're just a bag of
organs
really yeah look i mean there's nothing
protecting them they don't have
like they can't run they can't move like
how else would they protect themselves
what are they like it's why pigs scream
so loud it's like that's the only
recourse they have so they hiss they
spike
but they're so easy to kill
i feel like the more vulnerable you are
the tougher you have to be on your
exterior and you
are every person on instagram that
leaves a mean comment
you're vulnerable and you're just scared
look there's just skin under there
there's no like
like there's no
why them mice don't have spikes like
yeah and how well do their lives go um i
don't know and their lives aren't
they're not killing it in the game
they were like oh do you yeah and do
they they're my sons but yeah and they i
mean but they are the most
killable things you have a ball of
spikes i'm holding a fistful
of needles
right now
yeah which we i normally do at night
when i take my peptides i do like pain
speaking of pain
i love that you have found like
surrounded yourself with magical
um things from narnia
your life has been so
wild and you enjoy the little things and
have given yourself the luxury of these
weird little aliens
um
or is it adding to chaos upon chaos
honestly though
i am at the point where chaos when
people's that's a judgment
so when you say my life is chaos or like
oh this is chaos no all you're doing is
saying that you couldn't handle it
i can we have different tolerances so i
call my life chaos i can't handle it no
i'm saying you can i'm saying when
someone else goes you're so chaotic
you're so dramatic i'm going like no i'm
yeah
i do fuck this is my tolerance level
some people can jump out of planes some
people can drive like you can handle it
you're thriving yeah it's only chaos if
it's
not working it's working
you're on fire it is so it is though
you're happy admitting i'm a bear
looking but yeah you're not i just feel
like i shouldn't take your eggs it's not
it's
them it's
i think that
and we can cut this i think that in
order to make other people feel
comfortable
you have had to be like things are bad
things like things are people love you
yeah
is that a like can you live with that is
that okay like what happens whenever
when actually everything's okay are you
like
does it make you is it hard to receive
love is it hard to receive success yeah
it like what if the war is over
are you bored are you you know what i
mean maybe the war is over
no
like it could be like what if all the
shoes dropped
you know i think sometimes we're so used
to kind of shoes
no
like what is like same higher what if
like you have like five super healthy
kids and
i do
what if you have 29 animals and amazing
friends that are sitting here looking at
you adoringly that support you and blue
hair and what if you just have blue hair
and i'm in your life uh that's called
rock bottom and like
what if like because that's the thing
it's like what who are we when
everything's actually
okay
i think sometimes we're so worried
bored
or do we need to
sometimes
please don't bite me but you can if you
he's licking my ring shut up okay he is
spit just oh shit it's this weird thing
where it's like i think sometimes i'm so
attached to my
trauma sometimes that i don't know who i
am without it
i like i don't even sometimes i'm like
yeah you're right you know what i mean
no i do like chaos like you say chaos i
just go oh my god you have five like
amazing kids i have so many friends
whose kids are fucking
what like you have all these animals and
you have amazing friends like this could
have gotten like i literally when you
were like i'm bringing my friend alexis
i'm like we'll see what
what she surrounds herself with that's
how i'll know this is someone that has
looked us in the eye the entire time who
is going on a date who like pushed it to
be with you who is like so sincere who's
from canada you're friends with people
from canada your life's going pretty
well
people from canada like you i love you
and like
take inspiration from this these are
your new spirit animal i know we're not
supposed to say the um we should hiss
more
get away from me but you know i mean
this these are good inspirations i'm
using them i'm going let me hold you so
i can get a photo i'm using this guy and
he knows
he should hiss at me that's fair
that's correct
you know
you should hiss at everyone because
people do use you and they do want
something from you most people do
usually
you know
so these will be your new be a hedgehog
love your spikes they're there for a
reason they protect you and you need
protection because like it does feel
like you're gonna have spikes you have
like such a big heart like put some
spikes around it that's okay spikes are
good they're boundaries and by the way
other people need spikes too because
that's the way they learn then people
would be like oh i knew it she's a rich
bitch like fine people already think
that ugh fine i'm sure a lot of people
already think that that's the thing
where i'm like i like this i know how do
you be feel comfortable with being like
that's that's what they say that's just
failed when someone's like i'm like i'm
worried there you think i'm a bitch i'm
like that ship sailed so long ago you
know i'm saying that ship sailed
thousands of years ago when it was
already like inculcated into our culture
that any woman that has any self-respect
or boundaries are like a witch or a cunt
or needs to be like bro like that has
nothing to do with me like if you think
i'm a bitch or a cunt it's just that you
didn't get what you wanted you wanted to
use me and i didn't let you
but i ca i don't know how to do that
teach us teach me it's just like a woman
it's basically just like taking a
contrary action like for me for the
longest time i just go if i think i
should do something i just shouldn't
because because i just just don't
contrary action like if i think i need
to do before i solve a problem first
make sure it's my problem right like
before i try to rescue someone like
you're an adult why do you need to be
rescued you're 45 oh you need help
and when we help people we're actually
hurting them because we're enabling them
like when i started realizing being nice
to people actually
infantilizes them that's when i was able
to start was able to start standing up
for myself because i'm like oh the more
i help you the less you're going to
develop the skills to help yourself now
i'm hurting you i should let you go so
that you can have the dignity of your
own experience like you know that so so
like using your codependence to actually
take care of yourself because self-care
is selfish like everybody wins when you
take care of yourself you know and
you know what this is not like a
profound platitude or anything but uh as
i like to say
most people are duds
no
mostly milk duds most people are milk
dust white milk does you know what not
worth it
takes too long like enjoyable for a
minute and then a fucking hassle like
because that's the other thing i
realized recently when i'm like oh i'm
gonna help this person we do it on our
terms i'm like yeah i'll do this person
a favor right here's the number of this
doctor have you ever done someone a
favor once and that was it
it's wait where's the office again wait
what's the number i just got here oh my
god are you just are you describing me
to you oh shit wait they don't take my
insurance wait i just went to the doctor
that you got me in with because you did
me you did me this favor and now they're
saying i need to do this do you have
another referral and then you're like oh
it never ends there's no such thing as
like one and done
no
and here's the thing i feel like
i want you to meet like maybe one day we
can do i want you to like when i'm
getting hives dude i am clearly i'm
allergic to you're allergic to talking
to people that's true i do have benadryl
i take it every day
i don't have dilated but i will
injure myself and go to the er just to
get you some dalot and even though i'm
on a no morphine listed cedars but
that's morphine not do you know how many
people
love you no
we've had dave grohl we had you know
we've had
huge people on the show when i say
people like can i come by can i can i
like i had people that like run
companies like friends of mines that are
like that are like adults with a lot
going on very famous people adults not
children like adults are like can i come
meet her i love her
and i don't wanna i'm not meaning not to
take it it's hard to take it
sorry what like what like who are you
when it that
because it's like all these stories that
people needed you to believe to make
themselves feel better like that was
for them like having to like we hurt
ourselves so that other people can feel
better about themselves i'm just worried
that
i have this theory
i'm gonna get you a better job do you
know how i'm just i'm holding a hedgehog
so give me one second and i'll get you a
better choice
i'm breaking out into hives too oh my
god and my tits are itchy like i don't
know what to do you do have feeling in
there oh shit like i'm fucking having a
full-on like
like
honey i have cortisone too that i put on
sets i must say and i know i have to let
you go soon i hope i'm not taking
advantage of you
as i'm like sitting here going don't let
people take advantage of you it's 12 30
at night um
i don't want to leave you
i said something in an interview that
really touched me and helped me heal
a little like the one last wound that i
wouldn't let heal and i kept scratching
the scab and reopening and reopening it
you'd said something you're like i spent
so much of my life
you know trying to hide from the fact
that i was aaron spelling's daughter and
then i was like dude
it's so bad this is so badass i should
be proud of this he's awesome
that was like so
cool
like it it took a long time emotionally
i was aaron spelling's daughter then i
was donna martin and i'm like who am i
you're the the queen of the hedgehogs
i will do anything for these guys like
they love you so i
uh uh
truly look
i
i've had some hard knocks in my life and
i just
today is
you know people are like they're like
your wedding day like this is the best
this is the best day of my life
and i just want to say that out loud i
just don't think you understand how on a
daily basis even in the last couple
hours i've been with you
have overcome more obstacles than most
people do in a lifetime
just on this podcast
in the last two hours you have navigated
more emotional and physical obstacles
than most people do in a lifetime one's
bigger it's like your tits by the way
honestly i do have to upgrade my tits at
some point and i don't like when people
touch them so this might be the perfect
solution we should do it together by the
way i would love to do a um
a reconstructive sternum journey with
you
well i have this thing i have like uh
this
see i have something it's a i was born
with it like and people were like oh
botched chits i'm like no is that
scoliosis i have scoliosis scoliosis but
there's a term yeah
it's like i i always had an intense
yeah
i have so much
i want to do this forever
we should can we be real friends yeah
because i owe you so much like i don't
but i don't think you understand like
your existence in the world i don't
think you understand how revolutionary
what you've been doing
all these years has have been and and
for you it's probably just felt like i'm
just trying to like keep my head above
water
i just like i'm in the quicksand and i'm
just trying to survive yes but what
you're showing
women and showing people is like i can
turn every
every time someone tries to screw me
over i can turn that into a win it
probably hasn't felt like that but it's
like i
i i don't want to get gossipy and i
don't want this to be like clickbait in
the news that's not what i'm trying to
do
but just the fact that there was one of
your books you said like yeah i did
martha stewart's show she was like kind
of cold to me and i was like
this bitch said what no one would say
said what no one had the balls to say
wasn't scared was like oh what you're
not going to have me back i'm not like
so i think you don't understand like
hey fuck up that no that is that is
you're stronger than you think
and yeah i don't get it well it's like
people look to me and they're like
you're such a badass you're so confident
i'm like i am like that's what you see
so i just my goal would be for you to
see yourself the way other people see
you i don't know but there's so much old
stories and old like
shit
you just have to hang out with people
that reflect to you like you know that
um like when you look you're like
when you look in the mirror you see a
cat like i want you to like see the lion
that i see like oh my god the lion i
just see the most like resilient
fearless
like
clear
i mean you have five
children
and have written six but you i mean most
people don't achieve what you've
achieved in 50 lifetimes why do people
make me feel like i'm fucking nothing
because you're giving them the power
yeah you're like you're giving them
permission and i used to do it all the
time too and it was because it was
easier and it was comfortable and it was
like i'm going to martyr myself and i'm
i am so itchy i am i am in high school i
just don't want you to think yes i'm
like believe in yourself respect
yourself meanwhile you're in hives and
i'm not giving you benadryl it's like
it's because we had to
be broken for so long so that other
people felt better about themselves like
we and but but i still don't want to do
that but i dim my light
because i don't but it doesn't work
it doesn't help and it doesn't help us
it doesn't help them or us
like they're not better there it just
makes them sicker like we were talking
about someone before you asked me if i
was friends with someone before the show
and i realized like when you get healthy
the sick get angry i didn't realize how
many people i had in my life that relied
on me being sick in order to feel good
about themselves and i think for you
because you grew up the way you grew up
it's like who am i to have trauma like
it's emotional trauma and even though
there was like
wrapping paper rooms and nice shit right
but i always felt like
you're not allowed who you i'm not
allowed except who am i such wealth like
i
can't feel bad like that's for people
these the
the
like what does that even mean you know
what i mean i know what does that even
mean like that's that's other people's
stuff yeah
and
it's their stories and i'm still buying
into i'm not telling my own story and
it's like it's like yeah it's just like
a it's like a and you know what it is
it's like for me i think i got to the
point where i was like you know what
i'll totally keep minimizing myself and
hurting myself and dimming my light if
it works but none of the people in my
life
they're not happier it's not even
working no so it's like it's not anyone
it just
it it they then don't get to grow
they're only relying on someone yeah
uh minimizing themselves in order to
feel bigger so they're not gonna grow
i'm not helping it's like the first time
you're not going and i'm not thriving
they're not thriving we're both just in
a sick like codependent human magnet
syndrome of like it's like drug addicts
who are like no we're not addicts no no
we're not like we're both just holding
each other back but it's a lot it's good
but a lot in every now and then
once in a while
maybe fucking amazing if you weren't
holding bags of um
tacks all day
i mean are we talking hedgehogs here
wrapped in my extensions you know let me
tell you like you're this is iconic
i feel like animals like part of the
reason you and i connect with our
migraines our information they're
telling us yeah this situation get out
of it like our bodies are like nope get
out of the situation get away from these
people i feel like the animals that we
bring into our life when we bring them
are always
giving us something that we need and
you've just brought hedgehogs into your
life because you need prickly armor and
you might need to curl up more and stop
giving so much to other people stop it
oh protect yourself
your fucking tory spelling so that's
even more can i tell you because it's
like
it's even more traumatic in a way and i
know it's like a hot take to say because
you have all these kids don't know like
i i grew up without money but i thought
i lived in a mansion i didn't know until
i went to someone else's house
everything's relative yeah nothing you
don't know you don't know you're in a
mansion when you're a kid you don't
value that you're not like i need 50
bedrooms you're like i just need eye
contact from my mom i need my mom a hug
all you need is i got that it's actually
like for kids the smaller smaller is
better because at least you have more
proximity to your family you know it's
like it's and it's this um and you are
robbed of your own reality it's like you
have all these feelings when you're not
allowed to have them because you have
all this other stuff that i want it's
like yeah but that's not what i want
yeah you know it's meaningless to you so
it's like to get all this this these
meaningless it's meaningless
and it's like it's not ungrateful to say
that right
but i thought for so long it was
that's my shit i think that it's a
confirmation bias if if i hate myself i
can go look for reasons to prove that
that's true on the internet right now
think about it
the worst people i know the least
talented people i know are like everyone
fucking loves me i'm like i've seen your
comments everyone hates you you just
have the skill of only focusing on the
positive whereas i have the liability of
only focusing on the negative which
served me really well
until now because it made me
self-critical and it made me focus on
like oh that joke could be better or
this could be better yeah i could be a
better mom because you're always trying
to be better we're trying to improve but
we can't take that i want to improve and
get feedback
you work with directors saying do it
this way do it this way but now no one
you just got really sober
right
oh my god i just called you on it
like you're
wow i'm like dude i cuz i got hit i got
pissed i got pissed off i'm pissed off
that you
are you i don't know how and that you
helped me
take your power back how do you be like
you have compassion and forgiveness
so it's like i think it's we forgive
other not others not because they
deserve forgiveness but because we
deserve peace yeah it's like
it's the compa imagine what would have
to happen in order for you to dm someone
and say you suck you're the worst you
would have to either be on drugs you'd
have to have a psychotic break
you would what would have to happen
dilated
no you would be nice on dalatin these
people are suffering anybody that has
problems with us they're suffering and i
i have a hot take
we're the bullies
for when people are mean to us us being
like what are you fucking mean to me
it's like i get to be me
you get to be tori spelling yeah you get
to have two fucking
hedgehogs that actually actually
thinking about that in my fucking hands
spray painted blue for you and you know
it's also just this other thing of like
it just doesn't serve us anymore
i'm trying to get it just like doesn't
it i'm not there yet and if anything
you're there i'm not there bring me
there you're also a great actress like
act like act like you're there i can't
just like it's also like
like
what but what would you lose if you
if all of that because here's a we hold
i think a lot of the things like i'm an
idiot i'm stupid i'm ugly i'm fat i'm
never good i'm not good enough i'm not
lovable i'm not all this stuff that's
not no child is born with those thoughts
some they get them from somewhere right
no child is born being like i'm a piece
you know i'm so fascinated by even the
you know there's a psychologist that was
talking about when when you change kids
diapers you should never go ew
you know sometimes you do because then
it teaches them that their
their vaginas are or their dicks and
whatever are bad because all they see is
their parents going ew and they learn
like like all the little cues we picked
up on like
none of it's yours your hair is crazy
it's wild i know i look okay let's
there's there's
things going on have they died in the
extent i don't think so how much do you
think that they they sleep
should we google they're nocturnal
are they nocturnal yeah
so are you
coming why do your i love it these are
like this these are famous person
clippings number one they're heavy
they don't feel flammable and they've
got numbers on them i've never seen hair
extensions that have like
there's like a tag on it that's like
these are these were not taken from a
sex trafficked person these are real
and they were paid for and they're
expensive and i can tell
that's
not that's not vo5 hot oil that's
that is
that's real
that's olaplex
i know what this is this is that's a
that's fancy that's like a chris
mcmillan
shampoo oh it's nice that's yeah that's
old money that's old money that's like a
round clipping yeah that's um
cara stop smart yeah that's a real one
and then we sprayed them blue because
yeah we sprayed them a little bit blue
because i think on messiness i do think
on i i have to make everything a
business i do feel like if you do
different colors for the extensions
every time we get an extension brand you
love the test ball green i like it
don't spray the hedgehogs we can't i
don't know if that might not go well i i
feel like we have an extension line we
want a hair product line
no you're not
no you're not why not you're you know
what it is you are
authentic oh no this can't be good i
really
there's no one i would allow
uh
to do this
except her that is so cold um and she
does it with such a plum
now here's the thing about tori spelling
i've heard you're unapologetic i didn't
realize how
true that was now i know i never end
these in any kind of elegant way very
good do it end it but
the next book
or at least the next chapter
elegant
is like sweet is rewrite like you've
written six books you can rewrite your
inner monologue about yourself
that was so profound consider it if you
do like you're a writer you can rewrite
it forward
just yeah yes just rewrite yeah like all
these it's like delete delete it's hard
okay help me it's just old it's like you
know sometimes when you're um you move
to a new house and you're um you just
sometimes just drive the old house for
the first like a month just by yeah
that's like what we do mentally you just
like there's grooves that you just have
to like
you know make uh more and more shallow
by taking contrary action i also
we'll talk about ayahuasca and microdose
and ketamine next time also we're going
to have a cooking show can we please do
an episode where i take lunes and you
take ambien it won't be that different
from this one we're gonna cook our asses
off and then we're gonna sell it as a
book who's more charming than you who's
more authentic and
charming
what or maybe i have to do less i feel
like i'm like do this do that maybe you
didn't do less maybe maybe you need to
give away less of yourself
but let me ask you something do you like
this is an off-camera conversation about
what you want to do yeah not what you
feel like you have to do
and that's my in this narrative of like
being notorious
or a joke
do you have to keep doing that
i love you do you know what i mean no
naturalize
yeah
but what if it was that show but like
everything now i just wouldn't if i were
involved i wouldn't let you degrade
yourself or be degraded ah and we might
as someone that is like
understands
very clearly the comedy of
self-deprecation and like how to be the
butt of a joke
i wouldn't
so what's the evolution what is it i
don't believe in evolution i'm a flat
earther
i just i think that it's taken me a lot
you know what it was i had this moment
you know how sometimes someone just says
the right thing at the right time if
anyone else had said it it wouldn't have
hit you it wouldn't have
resonated one time my therapist said to
me because a big part of my
way to control what i thought control
people or
ingratiate myself with people with
self-deprecation which is like well
because i'm just an idiot and i'm stupid
i'm such an idiot sorry i'm not yeah i'm
an idiot i'm dumb i'm stupid i'm stupid
yeah um yes which like clearly i'm
stupid yeah right like you know what i'm
saying same it's by the way it's just
like fake fucking insane by the way you
might as well say like
celebrities eat babies like you're
you're basically wearing a tinfoil hat
if you say things like you're just being
a liar so
i was in in with my therapist who was
like a really hardcore trauma therapist
and her whole thing is like like she's
very aggressive and i'll be like i'm
gonna go visit my mom for christmas
she's like no you're not i was like in a
in a
a really rough addictive
toxic relationship with someone and i
couldn't stop talking about it i was
like so addicted to the drama and
addicted to the and finally she was like
you can't talk about him for 30 days no
more what do not because you're a d you
can't you just need someone to say stop
talking about it you're addicted to
victimizing yourself you're like you're
just on a loop and sometimes you need
someone to just go stop like stop did
you this isn't working yes she said for
30 days you can't talk about this and
she goes i'm not seeing you for 30 days
like i don't want your money i don't
want your money this is you're
re-embedding your trauma it's a it's a
it's like a it's a pat it's just old
this is old it's boring look what like
you don't you know what it is update
your software yeah you're not still
doing jazz or size you're not still like
like you're not still listening to dvds
you're not so you don't have a walk man
you're not using mini discs why are you
still thinking the thoughts we thought
30 years ago but anyway so my therapist
said something to me that blew my mind i
was um i was like i'm such an idiot like
i shouldn't
and she just goes what is that and i was
like what do you mean she's like you
just said that you're an idiot and i was
like oh yeah like oh i was
and she was like are you an idiot and i
was like i'm just kidding
and i was like no i'm just i'm a
comedian i was just yeah i was just
being funny yeah and she was like then
she just went
no it's not that funny no like is anyone
laughing
when you call yourself an idiot like in
fact what it does it just makes
everybody uncomfortable oh shit and then
you think that you're being nice to
people by making yourself it just makes
it awkward and then other people have to
go no you're not and then you're arguing
with someone's like yes here's like yuck
like i just want to get out of here it's
like when you when you give someone a
compliment they argue with you you're
just like i just try to give you a
compliment why do i not have to fight
with you about it when you
self-deprecate yeah you're calling me a
liar ah
so my liar no if i say you're amazing
you're like no i'm a piece of shit so
you're basically just called me a liar
yeah you're right
wild like so
you can't have it both ways
so i'm either i'm either you either
respect someone's opinion and then they
give you a compliment you accept it
or you're caught or you're insulting me
when you if i say like you look gorgeous
and you're like no i don't it's like you
just basically said you're a liar you
just call me fake you're so right did
you take venmo
which by the way is so funny but so
deeply tragic this is just called
friendship yeah
i want nothing i want nothing from you
except that necklace um
had my eye on that the entire time and i
do think it's like
like we pro we both i think relate and
that we both have a distorted idea of
what friendship is so fucked up it's
also like you know what it is and it's
also like um
in boxing like metaphors are the only
way i can get through life
boxing like if you're a heavyweight stop
stop fighting featherweights it's not
fair
like be friends with equals because
they're not going to be threatened by
you equals aren't going to need you to
be smaller they're going to want you to
be big and shiny and sparkly and you
no one want no one
that like anyone that needs you to make
yourself smaller like they're just
they're outclassed by you and they know
it yeah
you know what i mean yeah it's just like
leveling up it's like updating our
software it's like whenever your
computer is like we need to update from
safari to
sedona or whatever like it's just like
updating your software and it might mean
not texting some people back
i went to sedona it i was i
i'm
good it was so hot and miserable
bye
no i'm just kidding
i i can't tell you this is i know i'm
like i'm going to want to make jokes and
undercut or whatever but i'm thinking
about my best friend dory because we
talk about you so much and we have for
so long and i just
it is now my goal with you for you to
see yourself the way we see you which is
like the most resilient the most
authentic the most like you are such to
women
such a legend
and like the way you walk the walk and
the way you
embrace life's fucking bullshit in the
way that you have managed after what
you've come from to relate to people
in pensacola
like don't don't minimize that
like what is who yeah you've got like i
don't know if we need you know what we
need to auto block comments the last
thing i'll say i'm so excited that your
kids
get to have a mom
that isn't full of shit
i'm not but that's it people say
parenting is not about being perfect all
the time it's about i'm a fucking hot
mess by the way that is the best kind of
fucking parent because guess what
i grew up looking at someone pretending
to be something and then i grew up and i
got my heart shattered and my whole
world was blown up when i realized
everything was fake and the fact that
you're just like this happens and this
happens and i make mistakes and here's a
video of me doing this and i'm doing a
tv
i'm doing a tv show but that's how
everyone is
have you been to tampa
you're the least messy person
in this country
have you seen the news
you're the most together person in
hollywood
you just don't hide i didn't ever said
that you just don't hide it no see what
i'm saying yeah
that's it that's the only difference and
i think you need to hang out with more
comedians because we advertise all of
our
messiness we don't hide it we just go
like i did this i made this like it's
you just need to be with people that
aren't completely full of shit and that
aren't pretending to be one thing and
then have a bunch of skeletons in their
classes yes so we my life's work now is
for you to see yourself the way i see
you and to give me that necklace on your
time
i love you on your time
[Music]
four four four
[Applause]
you